Greg dunkin trust
experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day,
Ladies and gentlemen,
mandates Tonkin motherfucking,
hello.
Hey k a super hippie.
What's up?
What's going on?
What's going on my friend?
What happened to the commercials?
Ah,
fuck those things dude.
And those bitches in later.
Ah,
I realized somewhere along the line did,
it's all about the flow
of the conversation,
right?
That's what makes a
podcast interesting to me.
If I'm listening to a cool podcast,
I want the flow of the conversation
be as natural as possible.
Yes.
I think even starting with the
music probably should stop to that.
We'll add that shit and post.
Right.
You know,
the flow of the conversation is what's
up and the best way to get the flow of
the conversation bright.
It's just kind of get into it,
right?
Yeah.
I think that's right.
I didn't mind commercials later.
I just sit down with the
people and start talking.
If you do a commercial first,
you've killed the vibe like for
like five minutes more even.
Yeah.
I've been guests on people's shows where
they do it too and I don't want to do
it.
You know,
you don't want to sit there with someone's
reading off their commercials even if
they're really good at it.
Yeah.
Also,
yeah.
I mean that's kind of the problem is
that it forces you to do like I read read
when someone's there because you want
to get it done with and then that makes
you sound like a robot and it's much
more interesting to talk about the,
if you're using it or not.
Like what is it?
Cause a lot of this stuff,
a lot of the people are
advertising on podcasts.
It's some weird stuff man.
It's like brand new strange
technologies that are new.
You know it's,
it's all Internet based
businesses in a lot of that.
A lot of those are cool and Squarespace,
that kind of stuff.
Yeah,
it's disruptive and it's very
mild way like you find that that,
that the staff is like disrupting
the most annoying technologies.
Like taxis got disrupted by Uber and if
you consider like the experience of a
taxi versus Uber,
no offense to taxi drivers out there.
I'm sorry,
you guys are a,
I don't want anybody to be
out of work or anything,
but man,
the difference is so profound that there's
no competition like taxis or like you
know,
they've got that fucking TV in the back
where it's commercials or like blaring
into your face the whole time
and you're just sort of like,
it's if you feel like
you're in a traveling prison
because they've got the plexi
glass in between you and the driver,
because we live in such a crazy dimension
where people who drive other people
around have to treat them like pythons
or something and put them behind glass
just because that one guy with,
with the ice pick.
Well,
do you know how many piece on Ted,
one guy with the ice pack do?
Do you know what happened
in New York City one year?
No.
They killed some insane
number of gypsy cab drivers,
I think.
What a gypsy cab driver would they
call gypsy cab driver is someone who's
working kind of without
it was like pre Uber.
Yeah.
It was like they were working without
a license or they're working with some,
some shenanigans were involved and they
would these guys to bad neighborhoods
and shoot them in the back of the
head and they shot a bunch of them.
They showed a bunch of
them paid criminals.
It was like something
they did to rob people.
They take these gypsy cab drivers
deepen in New York City somewhere like
Brownsville or somewhere like that.
Shoot them in the back of the
head and then dumped their cap.
Ah Dude.
It was crazy.
Like it happened a lot.
There was a,
I forget what year it was,
but they had no idea how
many people were involved.
They didn't know who was
getting does pre Internet.
Did they ever catch the guy?
I don't know.
I wish I knew that answer.
I wish I,
I'm kind of serial killer or some kind
of who is either a serial killer or a
practice of robbing people
and shooting them in the head.
How hungry are you?
Like,
you know,
you'll have to be so hungry to decide
that you're going to get in a cab and go
through the trouble of blasting someone
in the back of the head to get how much
money are they going to
have maximum and a cab,
how much would that have?
You know,
I mean a few hundred bucks,
who knows a thousand maximum.
Who knows?
Man,
it's just hard to believe that it could
be a million and someone would just
shoot someone in the fucking head.
You know?
It's just,
it's weird when you get to a
certain number and people go,
oh,
I got it.
You know,
someone kills someone for 1 million bucks.
Like,
all right,
well it was $1 million is
probably really tempting.
You know,
for some people,
probably I don't,
but it's ridiculous.
You shouldn't be able to kill somebody
for a hundred you shouldn't be able to
kill someone for a million,
but for whatever reason,
if you say it was only for 100 bucks,
they kill them like somehow or another.
It makes it like more pointless.
It killed him for 1 million bucks.
I mean it really weird.
It's like a brinks truck for example,
like a brinks truck you can
cause you're thinking like,
okay,
desperate criminal needs some cash.
If I'm going to kill somebody.
And I think it's a,
obviously a terrible thing to do.
I want to have enough money to live
on it for at least a couple of months.
Not enough to like go bowling
that night and like that's it.
You got to get another cab.
If you're one of those
Uber drivers though,
I mean how much protection do they have
the Uber drivers from getting robbed?
Things along those lines.
Is it harder because of phones?
Right?
Yeah.
Well I guess the people are being tracked,
but I mean obviously the ultimate
frightening scenario is someone like steal
someone's phone,
uses their Uber App and summons that
Uber and then they're completely
untraceable.
So I think that's probably a,
a danger that the Uber
drivers think about it.
I'm sure they teach them,
you know what to do.
I'm sure they've been like
tutored or are they there?
It's gotta be safety courses.
They're taking for the inevitable
situation where somebody gets in there and
thinks they're the reincarnation of
Christ and wants to taste blood on a full
moon.
What it's,
I think at the harder situation would
be for the young women who were bothered
and nine young women,
women who are by themselves,
who get in a car with a guy that they
don't know and they don't know whether not
he's been screened
properly.
Yeah,
that's right.
Or faking being an Uber driver.
I mean,
how hard would that be?
Pull up in front of any club
and look at and be like Uber,
Uber.
Yeah.
Easy Dude.
Shit.
Easy.
So true.
I'm sure they've thought of that too.
Yeah.
Well I've had people try to get into my
car accidentally cause they thought it
was Dubar.
We rented the escalate.
Wow.
Opened the door and we're like,
hello.
And they're like,
we're a,
we're here for Uber.
I'm like,
no man,
I'm not Uber.
Hilarious.
Yeah,
man.
You can get in a lot of trouble.
Uh,
you can get a lot of trouble
out there in the world,
man.
It's so strange to think that in this
beautiful time that we're living in and it
really is a beautiful time,
man.
It's an incredible time.
Amazing.
It was so strange to think of how there
are still predators existing in our
ecosystem even though I think
it's much less than it used to be.
It's just a fascinating thing to think
that there's people out there whose heads
are just filled with psychic bees and
for whatever reason that ring driven out
into the streets and they
do awful fucking shit still.
If it just becomes more shocking,
the more a technology accelerates
those acts of violence,
they stand out more,
they seem more
barbaric,
they seem more horrific.
I mean that's really what's
fueling like the furthest,
most fringe left wing ideas.
That's like one of my number one
problems that I have with like super
progressive people is that our agree
with them on almost everything.
But sometimes the way they go about
expressing themselves is so ridiculously
over the top that they become annoying.
And how do you mean they become bad for
the cause or bad for whatever idea they
have.
But ultimately what are they trying to do?
They're just trying to write it all out.
It's just the going so far and they're
so ridiculous with some of the ideas that
it just by quiet,
Oh God,
where would I begin the
the use of language.
It's a really important one.
You know like the people that get like
super upset at rape scenes in a movie or
rape scenes on a television show.
People that think that men and women
don't have to adhere to gender specific
roles,
which I agree.
You know,
you don't have to,
but to think that that's not the norm,
you know,
to think that in some way gender specific
roles for people aren't sort of carved
out in some ways by biologists.
Man.
I gotta tell you though,
that is a,
that is a thing that,
that,
that idea is,
we'll be an antiquated
idea within 200 years.
I think that will be the idea that your
do your genetic gender assignment is the
gender you got to stick with will be
like thinking the Avatar that you pick in
GTA is the Avatar that you've got to
run around with permanently because it's
going to get easier and
easier to modify the body.
We don't,
we have no idea what's coming
down the tubes when it comes.
This,
the new stuff that they're
learning about how to alter DNA.
We have no idea what's coming down the
tubes when it comes to like futuristic
plastic surgery and the ease of it,
we,
we just don't know.
Oh,
no doubt man.
No doubt.
So when that happens,
it's cause it's kind of like,
the reason this stuff's
seems really weird,
uh,
to us is because mostly we've
grown up in a time where you and I,
especially if growing up in a time
where you used w there was no,
the words they're using right now is
not the words that they used to use it
with.
The word tranny was not an offensive word.
People would just use it.
They didn't know.
You didn't know.
So you know what the general idea was.
If you're growing up
back in the 70s or the,
or the early eighties.
It's not like everybody
was a complete her heart,
horrible bigot.
But at least I grew up in North Carolina.
So the public opinion on
transsexual people is not
what you would consider to be
rosy.
It's not like people are like,
they deserve rights,
they should get married and you live,
we're in a topic of discussion and
wasn't even a topic of discussion,
but the,
but now,
you know,
people are realizing,
Oh shit man,
I don't know if I have to be,
uh,
physically what my genetics are saying.
I have to be.
And uh,
so they go through this,
the thing Bruce Jenner's going through,
they take hormone replacement therapy,
I guess they get their,
their penis cut off and they get a vagina.
Uh,
and I don't think that you'd like
to have you phrase it like that.
How do you phrase it?
Um,
they get reconstructed.
Well the,
yeah.
Okay,
well that's scary.
Imagine sitting in when you're in your
Uber and the guy in the back seats as do
you want to get reconstructed tonight?
I honestly think that there's
gonna come a point in time we go,
or they're going to be able
to change you into anything.
That's it.
Anything male,
female,
you will go back and
forth from male to female.
Yeah.
I mean it might be a
thousand years from now,
but it's coming.
It's coming sooner than that,
at least in VR space because of the,
Oh,
you know,
the,
um,
I was just at this fucking crazy,
uh,
virtual reality gathering downtown,
cause I'm pals with this guy,
Johnny Ross.
He puts him on,
they had everything there,
everything there,
all the new high tech stuff was there.
They had the new valve VR prototype,
which is,
this makes my oculus rift look like shit.
But one of the things they add,
which was so incredible,
was a software that scans your face and
then turns that into the mask of some
other thing.
So if you're playing a video game,
you're theoretically,
your face would be sort of being scanned
and what it would look completely
different.
The expressions you are making in the
real world would translate into the
Avatar.
And that's pretty bad ass man to be
able to play an online role playing game
with avatars that are making real human
facial expressions and not just one
function of it.
Uh,
but it doesn't have to freak you out.
I love it.
Try to give you any pause.
It used to just go,
what the fuck are we doing?
I used to really not anymore,
man.
I happen.
I lifted my,
took Timothy Leary's advice.
What was it?
Lift up your legs and float downstream.
Don't worry.
Stop freaking out.
Don't,
there's nothing.
Number one,
you're not stopping it now.
It doesn't matter who you are.
It doesn't matter what plan you have.
It doesn't mean you ain't stopping it.
Elan Musk could take his clothes off,
climb on the top of the
empire state building,
and hold a banner that says AI is going
to destroy all humanity and nobody would
pay attention because you're talking about
something that seems to be more of a,
something deeper than
just human innovation.
It seems to be something like more of a,
a kind of momentum and an extra Robel
momentum in the direction of us having
100% control over the way we express
ourselves and the things we create and,
and not being limited by our current
meat bodies in any way at all.
That's where it's headed and
that's just one little piece of it.
It's not going to stop.
In fact,
this is the last age,
everyone should just,
you know,
go outside and look around and enjoy a
world where people aren't wearing visors.
In a world where all the clouds of data
surrounding you aren't being visualized
in a variety of ways that have
been created by programmers,
because that's what we're looking at.
Just the entire universe animated with
information in real time and people,
people's faces being
whatever they want it to be,
people's bodies being
whatever they want it to be.
I think it goes past that.
I think whatever you are as a human being,
you're going to eventually accept as
being a digital form because it's going to
be more exciting than the flesh.
You want to get to a point
where it's going to be better.
He,
the idea of you downloading your brain
to computer right now is horrific.
I'll go,
my God,
why would I want to do that?
Right?
But the idea,
if they can get your car and then
biologist say it's impossible,
but I just think it's impossible now,
but if they can get,
whenever your consciousness is,
they can get a digital image of that
absolute three d every molecule in exactly
the right place,
digital image of you,
and they can convert this into an
artificial body in instantaneously.
You will be conscious and aware.
Yeah,
that one's going to shut off.
This one's going to show it on click,
click.
Here we go.
Dunkin.
How are you?
Great.
Oh my God,
I'm in the mall.
He more,
Oh yeah,
you'd be a digital voice.
Yeah.
You'll be a great full,
it'll be a great voice.
You'll have.
Yeah,
it'll be great.
It's like,
it's one,
it's wonderful.
What's,
what's happening is wonderful,
but it's,
it is scary for a lot of people.
But man,
just,
just the,
that we have so many restrictions
on us that are based on our biology.
We,
humanity has just grown to accept you.
If you accept growing old,
you accept whatever your
particular physical disabilities
or talents have to be.
The idea that these could be enhanced in
such profound ways with exoskeletons or
with some kind of new,
a cybernetic red blood cells.
Uh,
it's,
it's crazy,
but it really does mirror a video game.
You know,
in a video game when I,
the character levels up and
it becomes a whole new game,
the game gets interesting again.
That's what's about to
happen to our species.
Like our species is about to level up.
It's about to become
an entirely new thing.
And it's a,
it's a few specific technologies
that are all converging,
uh,
that are forming this thing.
And,
and those technologies
are three d printing,
robotics and AI.
Um,
uh,
the legalization of psychedelics,
and farm psychopharmacology
that's happening right now,
the exploration into psychedelics and uh,
all forms of life extension therapy
and all of these things are,
they're meeting,
they're all going to meet,
they're all growing together.
They're all appendages that are growing
out of this sentient life form that
seems to be that we seem
to be headed towards a,
on our temporal spaceship
that we call planet earth.
And the appendages are sort of right
now we're beginning to see the first
budding growths of them
and the rudimentary Vr,
the rudimentary AI or the
rudimentary three d printing.
But the idea that you can
go into an artificial,
and I know a virtual space created by
an artificial intelligence that is a
replication of something that you
have stored in your memory that's been
downloaded and scan so that you could
go and live inside a memory in three d
space.
And then within that memory,
have some piece of it printed
out in a three d printer.
You know what I mean?
Like Holy Shit,
I'm hanging out at my grandmother's house
when I was six because they were able
to scan my memories and Tran
digitize it and put it in VR space.
Oh look,
there's that.
A pendant that my
grandmother liked a computer.
Print that out and then boom.
Now you've got a three d representation
of something inside your memories.
Oh my God.
I get that.
Where are we going to put it all,
but it will just fill the
world up with three d images.
Yeah.
Their memories will be just clutter.
There'll be the new clutter.
Three d images of your past.
Junkyards filled with old grandma,
append and go out to a field.
What does this,
what does this apartment doing here?
This is the apartment where I grew up.
I rebuilt it out here in the field.
See that mattress?
I came on that mattress.
That's my car.
I reprinted it with the three d printer.
Yeah.
That's what you're looking at,
man.
That's what you're looking at.
You or looking at,
um,
now I now the memory downloading stuff,
I don't know of any kind of,
I don't,
that's,
I,
I think that's a little bit of a stretch.
I don't know exactly where
we're headed with that,
with that stuff,
but I do know that they're
learning a lot about memory.
I just heard that they have,
they think that they've figured out a
way to restore memory in people with
Alzheimer's disease using some
kind of like sonic technology to,
uh,
to,
to remove the plaque that's in
there and the memories come back.
So we're learning about memories and
the more we learn about memories and the
more we learn about what
you are talking about,
which is this hyper realistic,
detailed,
super ultra HD scan of the human brain,
then if that is possible to recreate
consciousness than it makes sense that you
would also be able to recreate the
memory's encoded inside the neurology that
you're duplicating.
I think that's where I was getting at
when I was talking about this idea that we
are,
we're,
we're in this weird space right now or
this is all happening when we were like
caterpillars that are giving birth to
a butterfly or be transforming into a
butterfly.
Yeah.
And it's all happening right.
Right in front of us.
That's why these violent
acts are so repulsive today.
Yeah.
I mean I think there
were always repulsive,
but now they seem particularly
repulsive because you'd like badly.
We have to look what's going on.
Look how much crazy shit is going on if
we're still having religious murders and
all this is going on.
Yeah.
So it's,
there's this weird sort of
disruption in the potential of,
of the situation.
That's right.
And this weird disruption
is like being met with more,
more people are looking
at these disruptions now
than ever before and you're
getting extremes on that end.
I think you and I caught a
moderate in our progressiveness.
Right.
And we're both like
totally pro gay marriage,
totally pro abortion rights,
do whatever the fuck you want to do.
As long as you're not
harming other people,
but be responsible for your actions too.
And I think more,
more and more people are,
at least in my opinion,
what I'm running into kind and aware
that I think ever in my life time,
more people were kind of aware.
That's where people are also aware
of like the benefit of being kind.
That's right.
But along the way,
you're going to have
extremes on both sides.
You're going to have extreme religious,
crazy fucking people.
You can cause extreme left wing lunatics.
You can have all sorts of people.
Like Chris Ryan said it best.
He was like,
they're a fascist wearing hippie clothes.
Right?
They're wearing a hippie outfit.
Yup.
And there's,
there's that too.
But what it,
what we're learning from all of this is
that we know more about what's going on
and we know more about where we're
headed than we've ever known before.
But yet we're still completely in the
dark as to where this thing could.
That's right.
We don't know where it could go,
but we are the midwives of the thing and
that's the frustration is here we are.
All of us are,
are either via our attention or
some people like Rick Doblin and,
and the work they're actually doing
or our Kurzweil or Musk or any of the
luminaries who are at
actively transforming society
with their technological
innovation.
These are midwives and they're their
rue drawing this thing out there,
letting this thing be born and while
they're letting this thing be born in what
is being born is you can
call it whatever you want.
You can call it a renaissance,
you can call it the tech,
no messiah,
you can call it whatever
you want to call it.
But this thing being born has not existed
as far as we're aware on this planet.
And if it did,
it was before one of
those meteorite impacts.
You talk about some time,
but here we are delivering this thing
and end the fucking delivery room in this
incredible period in human history where
we're looking at complete control over
our genetics,
solving some of the world's
greatest problems solving,
like curing diseases,
uh,
that we thought we never could cure.
There's like assholes throwing
firecrackers in the fucking delivery room,
yapping about some
invisible angry guy that,
uh,
the hates gay people.
And that's really
frustrating because you're,
you're witnessing,
uh,
the most radical form of violence,
which is not just violence,
human to human,
but violence in the sense of trying to
destroy the potentiality of our species
by clinging to an antiquated and
ridiculous notion of what God looks like.
And that's,
if there is anything
more violent than that,
I can't imagine what it could be.
No,
it's,
it's the most archaic evolve beliefs.
The most archaic of all beliefs is this
magic man that you've never met once you
to kill people who don't believe in him.
Yes.
That Dad's bananas.
And this is,
this is one of those things that just
been around for long enough to get
traction and it's become
a normal part of life.
But if you tried to introduce it today,
if most people lived a secular life
and you tried to introduce radical
Christianity right today,
yes,
they would be one of the most ridiculous
conversations you could ever have with
people.
They would be the,
the news would report on it,
right?
It would be like they would
talk about the effort.
This strange new cult has come to town.
Then once you believe that a,
you were born from original sin and a,
there's a man who died.
They had a hammer him together.
He was a son of God.
They had a hammer him to,
some would otherwise they
couldn't fix the whole thing.
There's no other way to do it.
And uh,
they,
they wrote this stuff down back then and
we just passed down from generation to
generation.
And then this is God's word and that's,
that sounds like something,
if it didn't exist,
like if you're on the bus with
someone and they started saying it,
you'd switch seats because you're like,
shit man,
I sat next to the fucking crazy.
But what was it?
What,
what do you think the original Bible was?
The original Bible man?
I think it was a transmission that was
prepping the way for this thing that's
coming.
I think it,
uh,
one of the many in the same way you've
got Ilan mosque in the same way you've
got luminaries now,
I think back then you add luminaries
who are looking around at a world where
people were barbaric,
barbaric and getting
crucified and they were like,
okay,
you know,
look what they had to work with,
man.
You have to start with like,
hold on,
maybe love your enemy as you love
yourself or these ideas that are unifying
these ideas that can create real
peace because you need the piece.
If you are looking at what's
coming is the formation of a baby,
then whatever early religion
is propagating any kind
of diminishment in war,
any kind of,
or even the attempt to reduce violence,
then you're looking at this.
It's kind of like trying to create the
pod within which this thing can grow
cause we need peace.
We need stability in whatever
way we can get get to.
Now.
I'm not saying that the creators
of the buy of the New Testament,
the gospels were like,
Shit,
man,
we better come up with this ridiculous
idea so that there can be robots in the
future.
But I think,
yeah,
but that is,
it's all the process,
right?
It's part of the process,
which is why it's so ironic.
Did the people saying
there's an invisible God,
he wants him to kill other people.
Uh,
they're there while
they're doing all this.
The actual God is in the birthing process
in the laboratories and universities
and think tanks of the,
of the planet.
It's oozing through the human
imagination and manifesting.
Is it all these high tech
technologies that are,
that have as one of their byproducts?
The tendency to heal.
You're talking about people,
three d printing,
they're fucking artificial limbs.
Now think about that man that used to be
so hard to get an an artificial limb is
so expensive.
Like now you could just print it
out if that's what did Jesus do?
He went around healing people.
And you're seeing the very same thing.
Like cancer is like the,
the,
uh,
cancer prognosis,
at least in a lot of cases is
much better than it ever has been.
Not to mention the treatment of all
the varieties of maladies that we have.
I'm not like saying Western
medicine is the ultimate thing,
but it is helping people live
longer and healing people.
And it's in it.
It can be a very beautiful force.
Uh,
it also is an incredibly
destructive force too,
but it has a lot of wonderful byproducts.
So I think that it's incredibly ironic
that those folks can't see that they're
looking for a god that was invented
when the actual God is right in front of
them.
Uh,
and in all the high tech shit that
we see scattered around this planet.
Well it exists in the universe
wanting us to create it.
Whatever the fuck is inside of people
that makes us want to breed and make
buildings and keep pushing forward.
It's also the same that gives us
almost universally a desire
for better shit all the time.
Almost universally people are starting
to be so entrenched into this idea of
technological innovation
that all the new shit,
they're,
they're up on it.
They're talking about it.
You hear what's going on.
Yeah.
Masters uh,
creating a new laptop,
master's going to get us a 15
inch with a visual optical drive.
He reads your retina and plays the
w w we were all like master has us,
master is the machine that makes stuff.
Master master master is the
machine that makes stuff.
And the more of a ball where you are,
the more store flew gammas,
stove,
older stove and this idea that that's
success and that's based on not happiness.
No,
not the amount of positive interactions
you have between loved one.
Nope.
Not that.
Know what,
how much shit you got,
how many Zeros and ones,
how much of a boost or you giving to this
system that's trying to give birth to
an artificial intelligence.
Yeah.
That's how much,
how much money,
how much houses,
and just buy,
buy,
buy.
You demand the best.
We can reengineer it.
We can make it better with a
better model for Mr. Jones.
Mr. Jones,
was that the model that floats,
let's make the bottle with a hoverboard.
And before you know it,
it's going further and
further and further.
And for almost all,
it was fueled by this desire for Shit,
materialism,
market pressures,
as it's called.
And it,
and it's cool to know that that's
what's manifesting the thing.
It's not,
it's cool to recognize that the,
whatever the womb of technology is,
it's,
it's using everything.
It's using greed,
it's using altruism,
it's using creativity.
It's using every little bit of
nutrients that's floating around.
Our paradigm is being
absorbed into this being.
And you know,
sometimes like bs,
right?
Bees,
they're working fucking hard,
right?
They're out there getting Paulin.
Uh,
and I know this is dumb
cause they probably,
I don't know how it be might think,
but I bet that the B isn't thinking,
fuck man,
I've got to get more pollen
for the fucking hive.
I've got to do this man
to work really hard.
I think it's thinking,
God flowers feel so good
are all around inside of,
I just love rolling around inside of
flowers and I think in the same way humans
when they're doing all these things that
seem like recreation and leisure and
hedonism,
they don't realize it,
but they're,
they're building the machine to their
building the machine by their desire for
more heightened levels of hedonism for
heightened levels of sense gratification,
for heightened ability to
express themselves or to
bring what's in their mind
out into the world.
They're all worker bees that are
helping to push forward the birth of,
of,
of whatever this thing is that is
currently fermenting in the womb of time.
We're giving birth to a new thing.
I think it's going to be a life form,
but it's just not going to be a life form.
Like the way we see life forms.
We've,
we have a very rigid idea of life forms
and our life forms have to be alive.
They have to have sex,
they have to breed somehow or another,
they have to replicate genetics
through biological methods only.
That's it.
And that's it.
And then you have to have blood and bone
or something really similar that we can
map out and show the difference.
Like a slug,
like what exactly is slug,
how it's got some weird skin thing.
There's no bones.
Okay.
Yeah.
But that's alive too.
I get it.
And this is going to be a new thing.
This is going to be a new thing,
you know?
And along the way,
we're going to have some
fucking bumps in the road.
It's going to be real weird.
There's going to be some bumps,
man.
There's going to be some
serious fucking pumps.
No way around it.
You ever,
you know,
20 I Terrence,
I ever saw this great
Mckenna Youtube here.
Forgive me.
Every time I come on your
show on blab about him.
But the God man,
he gives this great description of what's
happening is we approach this event,
he compares it to a,
like a,
uh,
an airplane accelerating.
And the more you accelerate,
the more turbulence you get.
And so that's the,
that as we like sort of exit
the whatever the atmosphere is,
if the current time period that we're
existing in a move into this next place
that they're calling the singularity,
there's going to be some turbulence.
There's going to be some bar,
some serious fucking bumps,
man.
But,
uh,
there's gonna be bumps no matter what.
If we don't do this,
there's going to be bumps.
If every scientist on earth was like,
you know what,
let's not work on AI.
Let's not try to harness this power.
Let's keep technology exactly
where it is right now.
Oh,
we're fucked.
We're fucked.
Then we're super fucked.
Oh,
then we're just doomed.
Like if all technology
stopped advancing right now,
how would we be fucked?
Because the problems that are emerging
right now are so fucking severe that the
idea that human,
a human being or human intelligence is
going to be able to solve a lot of them
is a,
that's an optimistic idea.
We're looking at ice caps,
fucking melting.
We're looking at people
all over the world,
uh,
just out of control
humping like people are,
they're just,
they're,
they're filling up policies
with babies left and right.
It's happening everywhere.
No one's thinking about it,
man.
You one year of water in California,
one year of water in California,
apparently one year of
whatever that means.
Guaranteed.
Right now there's 50,000
people in California where
there's sprinklers on full
blast watching their sweet green yard.
They know there's one year
of water left in California.
They're like,
whatever,
whatever.
Here's the big one.
Golf courses.
Oh yeah.
Those fucking golf courses
play golf.
If I did,
I'm sure it'd be
sympathetic and I'd be like,
look,
I'm paying my money.
I want my fucking water.
That's right.
Can they water the golf?
The Ocean?
No.
Too Salty right now.
They can use reclaimed water,
water,
the golf.
So much.
I know about golf water,
the golf course course.
Can they do that with salt water?
Salt water is getting wrong is
he's going to fuck up grass.
I think you need some
nice pure clean water.
But I think that you
can use reclaimed water.
I mean,
I'm sure there are solutions,
but you know,
my point is we've got some serious uh,
difficulties facing us and um,
uh,
a lot of this stuff that we need to
fix some of these problems is that
technology doesn't quite exist yet,
but we do know that it's coming based
on the very predictable acceleration
that's happening.
Um,
did they call a Moore's law?
So we know,
okay,
well we can kind of guesstimate how fast
computers are going to be in 10 years
based on that concept.
And we can look at the problems that
simulators currently are capable of
solving.
Uh,
what,
what kind of problems can a simulator
that has the power of every human brain on
the planet sof?
If you ask that,
uh,
how to deal with the ice caps melting or
overpopulation or some disease running
rampant,
what would you think
would be move number one?
What would you like if you,
if you wanted to deal
with any of those issues?
I would think clean up the ocean
is probably one of the first ones,
right?
Chart.
Stop chopping down the forest.
Clean up the oceans.
Yeah.
Those are two huge,
huge islands,
right?
That's like a kid who like
wants to go play outside,
but you have shit all
over your bedroom walls.
Yeah.
You just shit on your wall.
It's like what do you do when you got
to know you've got to clean this up.
You fuck,
you can't just keep going.
That's right.
We've made this big mess of the
ocean and the F and everyone's like,
God,
I didn't do it.
Nobody wants to say they did it.
Like,
nobody wants to look at that chuge
fucking patch of garbage that's floating
around the Pacific Ocean that all
these scientists are terrified of.
Right.
Nobody wants to like look at that and go,
hey,
okay.
We did a little bit.
You did a little bit.
Let's chip in.
We got to do this.
We've got to fix this first.
Like nobody,
nobody wants.
Well,
nobody wants,
I mean the problem is nobody wants to do,
I mean just say no,
but I want to say no.
Governments want to do that.
Well,
no,
I mean fuck that.
How about November one two?
Well,
I mean I think people want to,
people that are super concerned,
they just,
I don't think they have the funds or the,
maybe the,
the means.
I don't know if there's a physical,
that's what we need that.
See,
that's part of what technology
can do is it can connect people.
I mean look at what it,
how great it is it raising money.
Look at how powerful it is when it comes
to any kind of goal that you want as a
society.
Just what you were saying is like a lot
of us are so brainwashed that we think,
well,
I hope the government
handles this problem,
but the governments aren't the ones who
are going to be transforming the earth.
It's going to be the super connected
citizens who are using technology to
manifest their will and
hopefully positive ways.
Yeah,
there's gotta be,
there's,
there's going to be no way in the next
five years to put a lid on this thing.
Oh,
on,
on the,
on the spread of technology.
Oh fuck.
Now you can't stop it.
I mean,
that's a verdict.
I mean there's,
if everyone might as well just give up
the idea that in some way this thing is,
is being stopped and everyone just has
to accept the fact that this stuff is
coming and also accept the fact that,
uh,
the world is a fuck load better
than a lot of people think.
And that's big.
And that's a big,
big shift that needs to happen.
I mean,
I think,
you know,
even as we figure it out,
deal with the oceans or any
great problem facing us,
there also needs to be a
deep and a prolonged ener,
uh,
work that people need to be having
with themselves because we are a,
Migdal Ezer going fucking nuts right now.
Have you seen this?
Oh Wow.
No.
This is a new robot.
Look at this.
You want to shut,
your parents are going to shit your pants.
Oh,
I've seen that.
I've seen that Gao.
Yeah,
I've seen that one.
Like a Japanese new robot
that they've created.
It's a woman and it will
blow your fucking mind.
You think you're being taken and
I'll do more than blow your mind.
I know.
It's the craziest looking robot
I have ever seen in my life.
It's very realistic.
So really super realistic.
The,
the youtube video is titled Very Real
Looking robot and it's one of those,
um,
it's one of those breakthroughs
where you look at it and just go,
oh wow.
I didn't know they were that far.
Right.
Well,
I didn't know they had got that far.
And you know,
man,
it's like,
that's cool,
that's fucking cool.
And that,
that's a,
that's an amazing,
amazing thing.
Uh,
and that's nothing compared and you know,
that humanoid robot thing
that everyone's sort of,
we've envisioned is what it is.
That's really like just
one little piece of,
of what we've got coming down the pipes.
Um,
and the other interesting
thing to think about is those,
uh,
beings,
the robots are going to be vessels within
which the AI will exist because the AI
is going to exist in the cloud.
So what's really curious is that we
will have this new kind of wind blowing
through the world.
It's the wind of the cloud,
of all the,
all the data that is now
become personified or
personalized by some artificial
intelligence and that
data whenever it wants to,
we'll be able to pop in to open a portals,
which will be robots.
So robots or cars for
artificial intelligence and
artificial intelligence isn't
going to be localized inside the robot.
That's what we all think.
You know,
you,
you go to the robot and you
like ask it the right question.
It's eyes bulge out and smoke
comes out and you beat the robot.
That's now it works it on the robot.
The fucking image.
Yeah.
That's the image.
So bugs bunny cartoon or something.
Yeah,
it's from Star Trek.
You're like,
good God.
Make a rock so big he can't move it.
And the robot White Palau it explicitly.
That was star Trek.
Well,
that wasn't the question,
but there are the ideas
you can malfunction or an
AI if you ask it the right
question.
That's a perfect one.
If God can God make a rock so big
that even he couldn't move it.
Yeah,
that's a good one.
Yeah.
It's,
it's like the robot can handle that.
You handle it can of pop.
That's what we think.
That's how you fight these things.
But the riddles riddles
fight the Robo with a real,
yeah,
but,
but you see you're,
you're talking about this,
uh,
it's,
it's very similar to a lot of mystical
conceptualizations of way human life is,
which is that human beings are antennas
for a transcendent intelligence that
tunes in to the specific genetic
code that is inside of every person.
That unique code is like
a radio station that the,
uh,
vast supernatural,
undiscovered transcendent cloud of
consciousness that they used to call God
tunes into or is channeled through.
It's the same idea with robots.
The idea will be there will be this AI
existing in the cloud that whenever it
wants to,
we'll be able to pop into a,
um,
a machine.
What's that sound?
Is that a car alarm?
It's weird.
It's coming through that
you hear in the headphones.
It sounds,
yeah,
it's freaking me out.
Cheeses.
Chamie
what could it be?
Maybe it's a toilet overflowing.
There's a car alarm going off.
Hopefully it's not yours.
I don't
thank my car.
The government man,
they don't want us to talk about this.
They love it.
The government loves us,
you know they do.
The military loves this shit.
That's one of the,
that's one of the engine's pushing
this thing next door alarm.
Sorry Ladies and gentlemen.
Do you think Dee Dee is
really a conscious effort?
Like people love what's going on,
like they actually enjoy it or do you
think that it's just this inevitable thing
that people are trying to profit
off of in one way or another?
Be a part of it?
Benefit from just ride this wave.
Just stay on the board as long as you can.
Do you think it's more that than it is
like they love it because it's good for
business.
Like that's how we would like to look at.
Yeah,
they love chaos.
Stay level profit off of it.
Oh God.
If only it were that easy.
It's,
it's just not that easy man there.
And you know,
when I,
I just interviewed Doblin
and he's talking about,
you know,
going into the Pentagon to talk about
using Mtma to treat PTSD with these high
level people and they're not
like you to Hippie Juror Aggie.
They're like,
oh,
okay.
I think we understand what you're saying
and that's kind of stunning when you
realize that this,
that that,
that,
that you can't demonize all facets of,
of the government.
There are people in parts
of the government that
must be an awful nefarious,
greedy fucks,
but also in there there's great people
who really want the world to be better
and to think that just because you
end up at with a government job,
he therefore means you're
evil is the most ridiculous,
stupid idea of all time.
It doesn't,
it's a lot of people,
man,
they actually want to,
they're not like us.
Like we're comedians.
We enjoy telling jokes and we have a
podcast and I think we both have our own
desire to like help the world,
but some people,
they want to help the world so fucking
bad that through high school they
volunteer,
they get out of high school,
go to fucking college,
joined the Peace Corps and they
give their entire lives up,
making very little money
to try to help people.
And those people,
sometimes they get into the military and
sometimes they get into the government
because they see that
as the most efficient,
obvious way of helping
the world and so yeah,
we can't do the whole black
and white thing anymore,
but some of those people are not,
oh,
let's have very high.
Some of those people are just like us.
They're like,
Holy Shit,
this is incredible.
Let's fund this and see
where we can take it.
Let's see what we can do with it.
Everyone's like that.
That isn't my best case scenario is that
our government actually becomes cool is
that the internet sort of forces only
cool people in the office and our
government becomes something
we can all tolerate.
Yeah.
That's a dream.
The ultimate thing,
I mean this,
the structure itself is really only a
problem when enough corruption exists to
capitalize on the holes in the system.
Yeah,
like the,
the,
the being influenced by big
money corporations twist
policy to suit their needs.
They could profit.
All that stuff's a problem,
but the system itself is not
the worst system in the world.
No,
it's not.
It's not awful.
If everybody was cool,
you know,
if you had an entire system,
have a think,
have a very nice person.
Who's your favorite person?
Uh,
he was like one of the sweetest,
most intelligent PR.
How Bout Dj Doug Pound,
Dj deadpan Dj Doug Pounds.
Cools fucks Mars.
One of the coolest people on Earth.
If he was in a position of a
mayor or governor or you know,
senator,
if the whole system was
built with guys like that,
it'd be the coolest.
It'd be the greatest thing ever.
Weirdest.
It would be beautiful world ever.
Every congressman Dj Doug Pounds,
that'd be amazing.
That kind of guy,
that Kinda guy kind of guy I was not
trying to fuck you over or just wants to
have fun with his
friends is very creative.
Very intelligent and very considerate.
Yeah.
Well that's possible,
man.
That's fucking possible.
We just don't think it's possible because
these wolves have been in office for
so long,
right.
Snapping at each other's heels and
the all the competitors at bay.
Yeah.
Woven it out.
Right.
Big corporations are stuffing their wolf
assholes picking up their wolf tail.
And it just packing money and their wolf
assholes and sending them out there to
do their bidding.
Yeah.
That's what they become.
They become these fucking dogs,
these monsters that are just at the
very tip of this hill that we're chasing
them up.
Yeah.
What sticks pointy sticks and
realize if they're gone.
It's like all that criminal corrupt
bullshit that we think of when we think of
the worst aspects of government a fall.
That shit goes away.
So you know what?
We're left with Dj Doug Pounds.
Okay.
Just cool,
smart people that make rational choices
and aren't going to give into greed.
Holy Shit.
And here's the other thing,
man,
it shouldn't be a full time job,
right?
You should be something
that you contribute to every
now and again when people
try to do our best,
like we all take turns
running the government,
like everybody gets a week,
you know,
and it's a fucking very,
it's a,
it's a very prestigious job.
Everybody gets very excited about the
possibility of representing our country
for a week.
Right.
And you go there and you do your
best to do the will of the people.
You make rational choices.
You all tried to talk it through and
everybody knows it's very possible.
One day you're going to get called,
man,
you're going to get a call.
I'm going to ask you to be the president
for a week and you've got to step in
cause you're a fucking
American and that's what we do.
Yeah.
And I go,
Duncan Trussell you are a president for
the week and you'll go on TV and you go,
I am so not prepared.
But I,
I promise as an American I am going
to do my best to do what's right,
to do what's ethical and to do it benefits
the greater humanity of the world.
Do it day after tomorrow
because I procrastinate.
My trainer was coming over,
I have to beat off.
What if that was like what happened?
Like everybody got to be the president,
isn't it
for a week?
Everybody has.
It'd be amazing if you're a duty.
It's a,
it's what you're talking
about is a beautiful idea and,
and I think that it's possible.
I think that's another crazy thing about
this time around is it's possible when
people hear that,
you know and obviously you're,
you're,
we're not talking about that literally
but with ideas like be when people hear
what you're saying.
Any kind of optimism right now in
general in the world is met with a pretty
severe eye roll.
I come on day,
I really think you can clear out those
walls tore talking about a fucking
government that is bought and sold.
It is controlled by the
prison industrial complex.
It is controlled by big Pharma.
It is controlled by the
military industrial complex.
These people,
their pockets are loaded with so much
fucking doe and they have been so
conditioned by a game that dehumanizes
people to the point where they no longer
see giant swaths of humans
and other countries as people.
The it is important to realize that
these wolves that you're talking about,
we're talking about a
different species here,
friend.
If you look at like what's going on in
the UK with these organized pedophile
rings,
it seems to consist of people
and the level of government,
I can't remember who it was.
One of the investigators said,
it seems to be built into
the system in some way.
Yeah,
look it up.
It's scary fucking shit man.
That's insane.
So when you look ahead,
avoided that stuff cause it bumped me
out when I saw those those stores with,
that's what they're saying.
That's what they're saying.
But here's the difference.
Here's the difference.
And that's horrifying to
imagine cause you know this,
we hear it.
It's so funny to hear it with the
UK government and people are like,
what?
But now you hear about a priest
doing it and people are like,
yeah,
that just happens.
It's like you're looking at,
you know,
an organized system that has
as part of the destructive,
a result that it reaps on the planet.
Also psychically wounding children
in the worst way possible.
So this is a,
uh,
I think that,
that the reason that that isn't as grim
and horrible as it sounds is because the
difference today as
opposed to 30 years ago,
is that we get to say it
in front of however many
zillions of people listened to
your podcast.
And it,
that info instantly travels
around the world 30 years ago.
If you think that if there truly is an
organized group of pedophiles that have
as their membership,
high ranking government officials,
not just probably in the UK,
but in the United States too,
if that really does exist,
it didn't just start today or
last week or two years ago.
That's been around for a long,
long time.
So the difference between back then and
now is that shit is getting everywhere.
It's everyone on planet earth
is aware of this investigation.
You can't get that genie
back in the bottle.
Even though I think a
lot of people are trying,
they're saying that the
whistle blowers for this,
uh,
are not going to have immunity.
That's one thing that the government,
instead,
if you're a whistle blower for
this weird ring of pedophiles,
no immunity,
you're going to jail too.
So they're like squelching.
There seems to be an element that
is trying to push this shit down,
of course,
because if it's true that there that
some speculate that even members of the
royal family could be
involved in this shit.
So yeah,
look it up.
I usually,
it's a deep dark David Lynch
level twin peaks shit coaster,
but the,
the,
that might be one of the
best descriptions ever.
Say that again.
A deep dark David Lynch level shit coaster
twin peaks style worms deep in the ground.
This is,
but,
but the positive thing is they're getting
exposed in a way that they could never
been exposed before.
So yeah,
I think that the,
that any kind of darkness
that is existing on the world,
it's very good to use the
example of Wolf's being
driven up a hill with torches.
It's just in this case,
the or Edwards,
the torch bearers,
or Edward Snowden,
Julian's massage,
all the whistle blowers who have the
fucking guts to reveal and eliminate this
probably,
um,
pretty built in old system of humans
that have victimized children,
victimized children and
the world and the planet,
and it seemed to take a lot of pleasure
from victimizing other human beings.
It's there.
It might be a secret religion.
Who knows?
Do you think that the reason why this
stuff exists more in the older countries,
the reason why this,
this system might be in place
in somewhere like the UK.
I mean,
this is horrible reality.
Like that Jimmy Seville guy,
that guy that was the
presenter on television that
it turned out was some crazy
pedophile.
Yes.
These guys that are in this country,
I mean,
England is an amazing country,
right?
London's fantastic.
One of the weirdest things about London
when you're walking around as you see
the age of things and it makes you as an
American feel like God might countries
a baby like this country has been
around for a thousand fucking years,
but does it not have the echoes of those
old people just like we talked about
before,
the echoes of savages?
Does it not have that?
Sure.
And don't you think that the
best case of escaping that,
it's almost like,
like literally escaping the
physical space of that contract.
So getting it and the people that are
trapped there and might take them longer
to shake that shit out yet.
Well,
especially like if you look at the
epigenetic research coming out,
the idea that,
uh,
phobias get passed down genetically
from one generation to the next,
then you're also kind of looking at,
it's a really curious
thing and this is pure.
We will hit be ramble.
So I get it.
Everybody out there is
going to tweet something.
How wrong this is.
But,
uh,
that if like I was thinking like these
countries where a war's been going on
forever,
if epigenetics,
if what they're thinking about epigenetics
is correct and that phobias get
passed down through somehow chromosomally
then if there is a place where war has
been happening long enough,
then there is the potential that encoded
genetically into the people who have
been living there is like all the phobias
and fears and terror that comes from
living in a war zone for hundreds and
hundreds of years that like it's the,
it's inside of them somehow it's
like made its way inside of them.
It's a really scary thing to think it and,
and that the problem that
we are experiencing is not
just our own inner turmoil
that comes from all the
laws and catastrophe that is
inevitable and human life.
But there were also dealing with all
the turmoil and catastrophe of our
ancestors and that,
you know,
the United States,
it's been,
you know,
our wars are happening elsewhere.
That's one of the spoiled Brat aspects
of our warlike country is that we don't
experience what it's like to hear the
hum of a drone and the suddenly the
incineration of a landmark
that we have grown up around.
We haven't experienced that.
That's why the motto of
the weather underground,
that terrorist organization
that was trying to homeland
terror organization that
was trying to protest Vietnam,
their motto was bringing
the war back home.
They wanted to blow up buildings in the
United States to demonstrate to people
this is what it looks
like when bombs go off.
We're doing that there.
So if this epigenetic shit is correct,
a lot of people living
in the United States,
they're not going to have
the same kind of phobias,
uh,
in their chromosomes that people living
in countries that have been exposed to
war for hundreds of years would have.
Yeah.
There's no getting around it,
right?
No getting you look at like bs,
like you look at a B that makes a beehive.
Um,
we were talking about bees earlier today.
Like what would it be
like to be a be right?
It might be some beautiful things.
Yeah.
Where it was supposed to be getting
the information to build that hive.
Why are they all doing
the exact same thing?
Right.
How do they figure out that they're
supposed to go get the nectar and then
they're covered with Paula and then
these fly over to the other flower.
Is that encoded in them somehow?
It must be if they can't communicate.
I think it's all doing it.
I think it's a,
it's a,
there,
it's a frequency that they're
structured is tuning into.
Like if you saw a remote control car at
tiny little remote control car zipping
around on the table and it was like
avoiding obstacles and going to exactly
where it would go if you were like,
let me look inside the car to find the
way that it's able to figure all this
shit out,
you would be missing what
was really happening,
which is that the car is tuning
in to a frequency that is,
you know,
the directing it.
So you place it and I mean again,
no,
it's a totally fascinating concept
and it might totally be right.
I mean,
think about how many different bugs
exhibit the exact same behavior.
All of them all over the world.
They have their own little groups.
They exhibit the same behavior.
They know how to build these,
these leaf cutter ants.
They build these gigantic compounds,
dig holes.
They create little areas
were like leaves for meant,
you know,
like it's,
it's a bizarre complicated thing
they figured out how to all do,
like it's not so out of the question
and think that they're getting that from
the sky or they're getting that from some,
some frequency.
They have a channel they
can tune it in and we can't.
Well,
it's,
and you get into like,
you know,
two dimensional stuff where it's like,
okay,
if it's epigenetics and if information
is being trance for not just in writing,
uh,
and not just in the teachings
of the parents to the kids,
but chromosomally then that means that
every living entity is the very tip of a
temporal appendage that stretches
all the way back to the big bag.
So it's not just an ant,
it's the end of the genetic line of that
particular aunt family tree that goes
all the way back through time
and it's transferring
information via a chromosome.
So this is a creature you're
looking at the very tip of it.
It's like what I'm Douglas Adams said
about mice and hitchhiker's guide to the
galaxy.
That mice were actually the very tip of
the appendages of a super intelligent
creature that likes to study scientists.
Ah,
that's beautiful.
It's so cool,
man.
Uh,
but,
but in the same way,
it's like every single one of us is just,
there's the tip of this temporal appendage
or opting into this fucking dimension
in that,
uh,
connected to us theoretically,
by the way,
don't ever fucking show of,
uh,
some of my stone or one internet article
on epigenetics or you won't suddenly
become a doctor of epigenetics
and won't shut up about it.
So I'm sorry.
But if that stuff is true,
man and memories are being transferred
chromosomally then that means that we are
the very end of it.
Telephone wire that goes back through
all our ancestors all the way down to
proto hominids and before that to
whatever fucking shit we were in the
beginning.
And that information is
like zinging up through,
through time and is a determining possibly
determining what we like and what we
don't like.
It totally makes sense.
I mean this is the most
recent civilization in modern,
uh,
modern world is America.
And this is the most recent version of it.
California.
This is like everybody got,
they land on the east coast
and they went fuck this.
And they kept going right?
And the really crazy fuckers
made it all the way over to here.
This is like the latest version.
If you go back the furthest,
go back the furthest,
you're an Africa,
right?
You're in Iraq,
you know,
that's,
that's the beat that,
so my assertion was always at that,
those are the townies of the world,
right?
That's what that is.
Like,
this is where the,
this is where the people started.
Everybody was left.
It's still believing shit that was
written down on tablets because they never
got a fresh influx of DNA.
Right.
There's still dealing with
the old operating system.
They have windows 95
and the machines right.
And they never got out right.
They never got out.
They're still there.
And,
and not only that,
they're dealing with loss.
They're dealing with
massive loss left and right.
A mass more than a million
people dead over there.
So the,
the there,
there,
the need for revenge is through the roof.
The madness is through the roof.
The loss of loved ones is all the
chaos that comes along with that,
through the roof,
which almost reinforces
the old ways of thinking.
That's it,
man.
Less,
it's less than new DNA.
It's rekindling the most primal of DMA,
the animal that wants to kill
the other attacking animal.
Yeah.
That,
yeah,
you got to let me listen menu.
If you live in a country where
wars happening all the time,
you got a lot to work with,
man.
There's a lot of shit that you've seen
in a lot of fear that you've seen,
that you've witnessed in.
And this is like this interview I
did with Doblin was really cool.
He's talking about one of the folks that,
uh,
helps out at maps is a,
is like a,
one of the descendants who,
and I can't remember his name now,
but who,
uh,
who is recognized that in these
war torn parts of the world,
uh,
if you really want to heal the,
the psychic damage has
been done to these people.
It's going to require Mtma assisted
psychotherapy or some kind of psychotropic
substance where you could get in there.
And I help deal with these,
these traumatic memories
that people have over there.
That has to be a part of reconstruction,
uh,
is not just going and build,
not just blowing a place up and
then flying in and being like,
all right,
we'll help you build it back up guys,
aren't we?
We're fine now.
Right?
Everybody's cool.
It's,
hey,
we made you a water treatment plant.
We did is we did.
No,
it's like you gotta get in there and like,
and not just there everywhere.
Like,
we gotta get in there
and we have to start,
you know,
doing a lot of inner work
with ourselves so that we can,
um,
so that we're not going
to fuck up once this,
once we hit a certain mph when it
comes to technological acceleration,
you know,
that's,
that's the thing.
There's two jobs,
work on the south and then,
uh,
do as much as you can
to help in the world.
Do you want to be the force of kindness?
You want to be that wave of
positivity that you're talking about?
Because the hope is that the
more that there there is,
the more it'll trickle
trickle a end to end to that.
As I'm saying this,
I'm like,
oh no,
no,
no.
Allowing people up,
man,
they're there.
How do you fix that?
You know,
I just write what's the solution?
There's one part of me that's like,
I know that if I know that the combination
of these technologies along with a
shift towards the positive
or the concerted effort by
a certain number of people
to turn their attention to the
potentiality of our species can create an
incredible change in the planet.
And then there's another part
of me that's like no friend,
no nuclear proliferation,
biological weapons.
Uh,
there's no fucking way to like,
there's no way to uh,
to stop it.
Is that true though?
Because if we look at life right now,
no nuclear war,
no biological war,
why would we seem to,
that's inevitable if we're smart enough
to avoid that right now with all the
conflicts over mineral rights and oil
in the fucking ad Arctic region and the
Soviet Union's plant and flags and new
spots near Greenland or wherever the fuck
they are yet,
we're just talking about
blowing each other up.
Like,
why do we have to think that Dutch?
It's inevitable if we're
all on the same trend.
If human beings are not tolerating this
shit like overall that we did before,
people were more aware of like
what we're talking about before.
Yeah.
That's one of the reason why it's so
horrific when you see acts of violence
today.
When you see someone
blowing up a mosque today,
when you see someone gunning
down people at a synagogue,
any crazy religious motivated things,
especially in us and people that you don't
even know whether they were the wrong
religion,
so he gunned him down.
Alex,
it's the worst representation
of the human mindset,
right?
Yes.
When when you're seeing that
and you're seeing the potential,
you're seeing this potential for oneness,
almost like a DMT trip.
You're almost seeing like a living,
breathing DM t trip,
right?
That is a rounded is gut ease,
organic,
frustrated souls trapped
in terrible scenarios,
right?
Without any of it being there,
doing born in the Congo,
born in Iraq during the war,
born in Afghanistan,
all,
all the above,
born in Vietnam during the Vietnam War.
All this stuff is going on at the same
time and all this chaos and fucking
outdated,
crazy monkey having a murder
rampage take Bonnie Shit.
Yeah.
And all that's going on right.
When the electronic DMT trip is happening.
Yes.
All together at once
and threaten each other.
So in,
in,
in certain ways.
That's right.
Well,
awesome.
Yeah.
Well that's what it seems like,
man.
And then you,
I mean,
you get into some really
tricky terrain here because,
uh,
you,
you gotta like,
well,
isn't this race and organism?
Well,
yeah,
I think,
I think it is.
I think we're looking at a super organism.
All of humanity.
Yeah.
Super Organism has some
form of schizophrenia,
super organism.
It's like a tree and every single branch
of the tree is a human being in that
tree.
The is all the,
some of the branches are
fighting with each other.
It doesn't know what
the tree yet and it's,
or another way to put it might be the
tree is fighting over what kind of fruit
to bear.
And the tree is fine.
Like part of the tree wants to bear
a super like radical Islamic fruit.
You know what I mean?
It wants there to be,
you want people to get
up early in the morning,
pray,
pray once a women to wear is
and it wants there to be that.
Now that's an extreme
version and I don't know how,
how enormous that population is.
Uh,
I actually,
you know,
when I did,
uh,
a lot,
one of my live podcast man
where I answered there,
there's a Muslim in the
audience in this guy was like,
yeah,
and I had him come on stage and
talk about isis and he's like,
we fucking hate,
we hate them.
Like that's not what it is at all.
That's just the most extreme,
ridiculous version of it.
Um,
and he was as sweet as could be,
man.
This guy was like the opposite of any
thing that you would consider to be even
mildly fucked up or dangerous.
He like saying this like beautiful prayer.
It didn't feel like he was
secretly anything at all.
It was a beautiful thing,
man.
It was really cool.
Of course.
So of course,
so,
but you know,
there's a lot of people who say,
no,
no.
The whole fucking thing's fucked.
That if we're really gonna
like make this a better planet,
then more and more and
more and more and more,
you have to abandon these
antiquated symbol structures.
We have to turn our eyes away from our
addiction to the past and like focus on
the now.
I don't agree with that.
I think there's a lot of beauty to
be harvested and all that stuff,
but still man,
it's like it's a complicated
problem because what do we
do when three d printers
meet DNA?
What do we do when you can
three d print and Ebola virus?
What do you do when you can,
when that technology is
accessible to anyone who wants it?
Because that's a problem is that we're,
everybody's going to have this level of
power and you really do just need two
people.
You want to like fuck up guns.
You want to fuck up guns for everybody.
What do you do?
You start shooting.
People start shooting people.
You want to fuck up and
inevitably what happens?
What happens?
Someone will do it.
If you,
there's guns,
inevitably some fucking asshole who
is either going to hallucinate a bird
talking to him or just have a fucking,
uh,
a chip on his shoulder about his boss
is going to go into a fucking place and
shoot up a bunch of people.
And that ruins it for all of us.
Now if you own a gun,
some people will think you're a
fucking asshole for no reason.
Just cause they don't understand that
it's fun to blow up things at a firing
range.
It's just fun.
Nothing,
nothing else.
I just like watching skeet explode
from time to time I have theirs.
That's it.
It doesn't indicate some
darkness in my heart.
It's fun to be outside.
It's fun to watch shit blow up.
It's fun to hear big booms.
It's fun.
So,
uh,
anyway,
that's beside the point.
The point is,
that's a gun,
right?
The fucking guns that are coming,
man,
this shit that's coming down the pipes,
the fact that you're going to be able
to have some wet works bio lab and your
basement and harvest
some kind of weird shit.
Uh,
the,
the weaponry that's going to be accessible
to people in the future is going to
be way more powerful
than what we have now.
And that's the scary part.
Don't you think that's kind of built
into the system that in order for us to
progress to this next level,
the only thing that's holding us back
is that there's going to be a certain
amount of people that are left behind.
So the idea is the system is almost
ensuring by providing almost everyone with
the same technological
capabilities to destroy the world,
that we all have to get it together.
Like you have to force people to
take care of all the fucked up spots.
Literally.
We have to literally embrace the idea
of us as a super organism and they any
spot we see that sick,
we have to heal it immediately.
We can't look at some
cancerous thing and go,
I'm not even gonna get that checked out.
What's cancerous?
The worst aspects of skid row skid rows,
cancerous skid row is a,
if you haven't been and you go to la,
really should go through
downtown and see skid row.
Cause it's shocking.
It's,
it's,
it's one of the most densely
packed representations of
people with mental health
people,
despondent,
drug addicts,
all these all jammed into this area
and they're all living out of boxes.
And it's like,
it's one of those things
where you just go,
okay,
what is anyone going to do?
Anything?
Like what are they going
to do is just come up.
Yeah.
Put up places to feed them.
You know,
is there a way to fix this?
Is there a way to help these people?
Is there a way,
is there a way to get the medication?
Do you did get them counseling?
Is it,
is there a way,
like what can we do like,
or is everybody just gonna ignore that
you have a cancer in the middle of your
city?
Yeah.
I'll give you drive by that.
That's a spot that's sick.
Like that.
Spot Sec.
That's,
if that's us,
if that's not us in our best versions
of Duncan Trussell go on hiking.
Yeah.
We're going to Laurel Canyon.
[inaudible] hey everybody.
I'm drinking water.
Yeah,
I got a new trainer.
Yeah.
There's that.
And then there's this,
yeah.
You know,
and you see,
you see skid row,
you go,
okay,
what the fuck is going on there?
What are you gonna do with
those pieces of Congo?
What are you to do with India?
What are you gonna do with all parts?
Me Mean India,
which part of India?
Most of it.
How about there's three times as many
people and one third as much room as
America.
Right.
And they're going to keep going to,
right.
They're going to keep your
having sex with people.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and uh,
yeah.
So that's a problem,
man.
It's crazy.
So,
but in see the,
but that's where you get in
a real interesting terrain,
which is that okay,
because the thing that
you're talking about,
I'm pretty sure it's going in
and cleaning up the cancer.
It's almost totally socialism.
It might make Alex Jones butthole suck
so far inside of him that it would cause
the singularity gyros and he would,
he would be very upset.
Clean up that cancer.
What are you going to do?
Put Them in camps?
What are you going to me to amps.
Yeah.
You're going to put them in
Phoenix cause it is that that
though it's the,
it's kind of the opposite.
It's kind of figure out
some way to give them,
Huh?
Will mean we will look at it
like if you look at skid row,
how much money would it cost?
X Cleanup,
skid row,
how much money would it
cost to almost a sign.
Like a swat team of specialists that can
like re introduced homeless people back
into society and the in a
comfortable way and get them jobs,
train them and like have money but to,
hold on a sec.
Sorry.
How much money would that cost?
Would there be even what the
Iraq war costs and a day,
right?
I mean you could fax true.
You could fix jai hidden
spots on earth with,
with money and everybody's like,
ah,
you can't just throw money at the problem.
It's our tax dollars as I'm talking
about the exact same tax dollars.
Redistribute it.
That's cool.
If you,
if you really don't like the
government taking your tax dollars,
I completely understand.
But guess what?
You don't have any choice now
as to what they do with it.
Right.
Wouldn't you be happy if they took the
same amount of money and they just put
more of it towards that?
More of it towards fixing up all these
fucked up neighborhoods where everybody's
born and to severe poverty.
That's cool.
That's a fucking cancer spot.
And that you could call me socialists
cause I kind of am with that,
with that kind of stuff.
I kind of am.
I am with people that are
trapped in bad circumstances.
I am with babies,
I am with that grow up
in horrible environments.
I'm totally socialist.
Yeah.
I don't think those kids should have to
pull themselves up by their bootstraps.
And I think there should be a way that
we prevent these people that live in the
worst spots in the world from,
from continuing with that
horrible like state of living,
that horrible quality
of life where you're,
you're getting sick all the time.
Like Justin Wren,
who's a friend of mine from the UFC,
he used to fight in the UFC and now he's
been working with the Congos and the
pygmies.
And these pygmies in the Congo is like
the sweetest people and he helps them.
He gets a medication.
We helped fund wells there.
Yeah.
And we,
we,
we get people that donate money on bitcoin
and I matched the money and then we
bought wells.
It's dude,
it's,
this guy's the coolest.
But these,
the,
these people didn't ask
to be born there man.
And they have these bulging stomachs
because these little kids have all these
parasites inside of them
and they have bad water.
It's one of the reasons why
so many of them gets sick.
Is this case going over there man?
And this guy is helping these
people in a very tangible,
very real sense.
He's right there in that.
And when,
when you,
when you see that someone
out there is like that,
it's like it gives everybody
a like a little more hope.
Yeah.
That's what we have to do this,
what we have to do is make sure that
all those spots where there's people,
all the spots for these people,
they get brought up,
took a normal way of living,
like a normal way of living
Madison Education Shan food.
We can do that,
we can do that and all we have to do is
just put different people in charge of
getting all the money right,
but just prop the other people
pro instead of war profiting.
You just have like hope profiting.
Yeah.
All these different organizations that
people are like drawn to and they want
like a guy like Justin wren drawn to,
he has to go over there.
He spent six months over there,
he gets malaria,
he got fucking malaria.
Fuck yeah.
Fuck these people are out there,
man.
They're out there.
And then the idea is like instead of does,
instead of like recognizing
those people are out there,
recognize that they're out there
and then become one of them.
That's the next step.
But come one,
you know it's like this Guy Cornfield,
a Jack Kornfield.
This Buddhist teacher
tells me about Buddhism.
He says,
we don't want you to be a Buddhist.
We want you to be the Buddha.
Don't be a fucking,
don't you?
You want to become that
you and anyone can.
That's the other thing,
man.
You can instantaneously right now by
calling the number on your screen.
You can instantaneously right now,
no doubt about it within the next hour,
regardless of your economic situation,
give some percentage of what you have
in a way that's probably barely going to
affect your life to some cause that in
mass would create what you're talking
about.
The healing beam,
the transformation,
this shift,
it could easily be dealt with.
You could do it right this second.
It's could and it could
also be done with taxes.
It could be,
it can be needs to be both.
It's not just taxes.
Cause again that goes
back to the government,
the government,
government,
the government at least we
could look at the books,
private citizens to start open up
companies and go over there and do charity
work.
And we ended up pocketing
a lot of the money.
Like it's still hits us
back at the core level.
We got to figure out a way to eliminate
greed and figure out a way to elevate
people up to like a normal health status.
That's right.
Like modern living.
If they want to,
but what if they don't want to,
if they don't want,
I mean there's a lot of people
that live in the jungle of Brazil.
They probably was like,
fuck this man,
I like it right here.
Or like the guy I pass next to the seven
11 yesterday I saw shoot up with black
tar heroin.
He,
I don't know if that,
if like,
I don't think that's getting to like,
I can't imagine what conversation and
like some nice air condition dome I could
have with that guy that,
but you know what,
that's not fair.
Who knows what if you
gave him my beginning,
what if there was,
or what if we developed like an actual,
you know,
super cure for addiction and you
could like snap him out of it.
Well listen man,
I had a guy on my podcast today
and he was really interesting.
Dr. Andrew Hill and uh,
he's the guy who created this stuff.
It's like a nootropic blend.
It's called true brain,
like three different ones
and tribes if you want.
That was good.
I had the one with
caffeine earlier anyway.
Very,
very cool.
And interesting guy and he was
talking about this very thing.
Well you know,
and you know this very thing is uh,
this is uh,
a lot you know about
singularity university Kurzwell
and d I think his name is
Dia Mondelez.
You wrote this book abundance.
I,
I can never get his name right,
but so basically the idea is,
um,
what are the world's big problems?
How do we fix them using the
law of accelerating returns?
And it's really the thing you're
doing right now is the most,
is,
is almost as important
as fixing the problem.
It's like what Tim Ferris told me when
he was interviewing like super wealthy
people.
He said they asked better questions.
It's the question,
it's like fearlessly asking
the big fucking questions.
Like what do we do to heal skid row?
How do you fund wha how do you get fresh
water to all the parts of the world
that are currently drinking diseased?
What,
how do you do it?
And how do we use this new technology,
this new emergent technologies?
Is it to get that to people?
Well this was this guy.
Specialty is one of his specialties is
using neurofeedback to cure people of
Adhd to cure people of all sorts of
issues by figuring out a way to give them,
to empower them,
how to manipulate their brainwaves
all done through technology,
all legit aboveboard all
know woo stuff at all.
All fascinating biofeedback stuff.
Super Open minded guy.
We like really fascinated about the
concept of fixing certain addictions and
weird behaviors by monitoring
neurofeedback and figuring
out how the mind works.
Really interesting stuff dude.
Really,
really cool that some,
some of this stuff that they've created,
they've been able to eliminate seizures
and people who are epileptic by giving
them the ability to manipulate
the way their their mind more.
Wow.
Like changing the gears in your mind,
teaching you how to manipulate
it and move it and train it.
Wow.
Really,
really mainly fascinating stuff.
So when you know that guys like that are
out there that are doing this kind of
shit,
it's like Ibogaine is one,
but he was talking
about a bunch of things.
He was telling a bunch of things.
Even sometimes shock
therapy when he says is,
it's what seems to need to to happen is
it needs to be a complete reset of the
system.
Then he said a bunch of medical terms,
I don't remember.
I'll have to go back over and listened
to exactly how he described it.
It happens,
but he said that these transformative
experiences are like very,
very important for
resetting and reshaping.
Essentially what we've been saying,
it's like you operate on momentum.
You just like got the momentum,
the world clipping it,
your heels,
and it's almost like you
can't get out of your own way.
All right,
so this guy is talking about it
from a neuroscientist standpoint,
so it's really interesting to get like a
guy who really knows what the fuck he's
talking about.
Kind of affirm what your
suspicions might be,
some sort of a vague way,
you know?
I mean,
your suspicions being like the reset
that comes from a super duper psychedelic
trip.
Very.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
Right.
Yeah,
man.
You know,
like you need to step outside yourself.
Yes.
And,
or you know,
the reset that comes when you have some
tragic event happened in your life or
their resets.
Yeah.
It's always that moment where you're like,
oh shit.
Cause it's like it's,
it's kind of like a bit,
a really intense game of make believe
that's what society is like everybody's
playing these roles in it and everyone's
really committed to the game and the
most intense way possible.
And you get so committed to the
particular role that you're playing,
whatever it may be that you forget that
that's just one roll out of an infinite
number of possible ways
that you could be a,
you could be,
you could,
you don't have to be stuck in your
current system of predilections or to like
really like break it down.
You're people are either
attracted to certain people,
tend to be attracted to,
things are repelled by things,
right?
And the things that you're attracted to,
some people aren't attracted to and
the things that you're repelled by,
some people are not repelled by.
They're attracted to.
So the question is,
how much can you change your levels
of attraction or desire and aversion?
How,
how trapped are you in that,
uh,
in,
in whatever that your particular modality
is a I can you get out of that and you
sure as fuck can.
And these,
the psychedelic trips,
um,
are,
are definitely one way.
Meditation is another
way to figure it out.
Yeah.
It seems like we,
we,
whoever we are,
where we are operating on some sort of a,
an operating system and that
operating system is your personality.
It's like it,
it allows you to go through this life
with some sort of a weird semblance of how
things are going to be because
you know how they just were.
Yes.
And it can be empowering or it
can be extremely disempowering,
especially if you don't like
certain aspects of your past.
You know,
if they,
you,
you were frustrated
with them defining you.
Yeah.
And that's where things like psychedelic
experiences can really come in handy
because they jolt you out of this or
the death of a loved one could have a
similar effect,
you know,
obviously much more tragic and
much more difficult to get out of.
But if you know,
you talk to someone and
they lost a loved one,
regular trivial bullshit is really a
knock on affect them the same way it's
going to affect someone
is living a bored life.
Who wants to gossip about shit.
If someone loses their mom,
they don't want to gossip
about knots and man,
you know,
it's like there's just
this reality of things.
It's totally different.
Well,
people can go and when they'd go,
you,
you're going to miss them,
you're going to miss your loved ones and
then we're all going to get out of this
one time or another while I,
while everybody else is going.
Well,
that's where it becomes
simultaneously tragic.
And then on top of it,
there's that DMT thing that
you get taught where it's like,
right,
yes,
your mom died gas wise,
you're going to die too and everyone's
going to die and everyone's already died
and there's so many people
have died before you.
And then somewhere in there,
cause you know,
man,
that thing you're talking about there,
the waking up that happens from
it death that involves grief.
Uh,
that's like the very beginning part of
the thing that you're given when a parent
dies,
but then the next thing you're given
is the after that is pretty fucking
incredible.
Which is that you realize that they're in,
they don't seem to be gone that day.
You know what I mean?
That even though that their
physical body isn't here anymore,
you really do feel them in
certain ways inside of you.
Not in a delusional way.
Like,
oh,
the spirit of my mom
is following me around.
But it feels like you can feel your
mom and your heart all the time.
Always there all the love that they
give you all this thing behind all the
bullshit.
Everyone's got bullshit
cause we're human beings.
But the thing behind all that,
that's what sticks around inside of you.
And it's really,
it's really beautiful.
And I think,
you know,
whenever I take a DMT trip,
because my tendency is for my attention
to go to the grief for my attention to
go to the,
Oh God,
I don't want to die and I don't
want to lose anybody else.
And I,
I can't believe how many
people are going to die.
And everyone's going to that
my attention habitually,
it goes to there.
But whenever you like smoked DMT,
one thing that I've
noticed when I've done it,
uh,
outside of whatever the
statute of limitations,
what ways is that,
uh,
you're immediately given this view of
one of most beautiful things you've ever
seen in your life and there
appears most beautiful,
the most,
perhaps the most beautiful.
Then there's sin.
There's,
there's sentience to it.
It's alive.
However,
for whatever reason,
it does not feel like
it's coming from you.
It feels like it's outside
of the things alive.
And you're like somebody,
you're like somebody,
you just had a hard day at work and just
walked into the ultimate surprise party
where everyone's like,
hi.
And it's like,
Oh God,
it's beautiful,
but I'm so fucking tired.
I'm so sad and I feel like shit.
And it's like the,
uh,
the message it gives you is right.
See,
you are clinging to this
identity of the sad,
tired,
unhappy person.
But if you just let go for a second,
you're going to have a really
good time at this party.
You know,
and that's the identity reset that I
think that they're talking about and it's
so possible cause that's a game.
The game of the hunched over businessman
with a briefcase and the weary face in
the big size and the depressed tweets.
Ooh.
Oh Man.
Just fucking world.
That's a role.
You are playing a part.
You are like,
you are like fucking Daniel Day Lewis
and you are committing fully to the part
of the Moby depressed businessman,
businessman.
That's a part and you're winning awards
for it left and right in the form of all
the people who secretly hate
you or all the people who are,
who,
who you make feel sad or all the,
all the,
you're having a real effect in the world.
Well when you,
when you try to sell someone something,
you were in a suit and tie or
aren't you doing a ritual dance?
Yes you are.
Yes,
you are a hypnotic dance.
You're throwing up those fucking tail
feathers and sucking in the gullible.
Yeah,
it's a dance.
Let me tell you something,
I can make you a deal.
And then when these 2014 F-150,
they changed the structure to aluminum.
But I'll tell you what,
I don't like it buddy.
I like the old steel.
I like the good old steel and I'm
wearing a real good deal on that.
Joe.
You have a way of talking to him.
Ah,
ah.
That's what salesmanship is.
It's really good acting.
Yeah.
And that's what being a pickup artist is.
And that's what,
yeah,
it's the same idea.
It's pickup crates.
It's trickery or it's like,
yeah,
but,
but a cool thing to realize is,
and it's a fun thing to realize and
it's a blast when ms thing to realize,
and it's just,
for me,
it's blasphemy.
It's because you want to believe that
you're a victim and you want to believe,
nice to feel like you
can blame other people.
It's the best.
It's the best to come home and split the
fucking briefcase down and take the PSI
and sink down into your couch.
Now you've got an excuse to slurp back
that fucking whiskey that you've been
trying to pour all over your,
uh,
happiness.
Um,
it's frozen under the fucking ice,
uh,
of the role that you're playing.
It's fun.
It's fun to be like that,
but the psychedelic,
the,
the psychic,
the mushroom,
the psychedelic reminds you.
It won't let you get away with that.
It's like,
no,
no.
I'm sorry friend,
but you're in the garden of Eden.
It's beautiful here and perfect.
And I'll get ready for
some really bad news.
You're perfect.
We love you.
You're wonderful.
You're forgiven.
You haven't done anything bad.
Everything that you think
is bad is something that you
did when you're in a kind
of dream,
you were sleepwalking.
We don't care.
We love you no matter what.
And whenever you're ready to accept
that we're right here for you.
And that sucks because
if you're really hooked,
I'm being Elliot Smith and you're really
getting off on that fucking dark hell
that you're in.
It's a little annoying to realize like,
Yo,
you're fucking given away the thing.
Mandel let people know
I'm committed to this.
It's like they say Daniel Day Lewis,
he had to get carried around during my
left foot by the crew cause he committed
so much to the role of being a paraplegic.
Did they had to carry him
from one place to the next?
Cause the way he acts,
it's incredibly disruptive to him.
If people talk to him is Daniel Day Lewis
that he wants to be the role that he's
in.
So in the same way,
when DMT comes along and is like,
um,
Mr. Lewis,
no,
that is not who I am.
I am a depressed man who is middle
aged and is terrified and is trying to
control people.
You aren't acting the
way I want them to act.
I am not fucking Mr Trussell,
whoever you just called me.
I'm not a being of love.
I am a being of darkness.
And it's like,
no,
you're just playing.
Make believe,
man.
You don't have to keep playing that.
You have shiny shoes.
You have shiny slippery shoes on.
Yeah.
Why do you have a tie clip on?
Why do you have that?
Why are you wearing a fucking,
why are you wearing a noose?
The geometric patterns on it.
Oh,
you know,
that's one of the things that
those secret service suits,
like any guy,
what has to wear a tie on the job.
They all have clip ons.
You can't choke those guys.
All right,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
But,
but you know,
if you're a business is
not being a businessman,
is any better or worse than any
other role that you're playing?
It's what's bad is when you forget
that you're playing the role.
Well,
the,
the realization that you've come
to wall on a psychedelic trip,
that'll have to be almost the
realization that everybody comes to when
technology and an information like
they meet head on when we hit,
when we hit the puff,
the fork in the road,
the tip of the spear.
If you get to the part where both sides
are moving in like an unstoppable pace,
there's gotta be a way,
has got gotta be a way to
bring everybody into the party.
Yeah.
And if you don't,
if,
if more people don't know about it,
if more people don't experience this,
this pause in history where people across
the entire planet are waking up and
saying,
wait
a minute,
this thing,
this whole thing might not be what we
think is this whole thing might not be
what we think it is.
This crazy desire that we have is finite
life forms to build a nest egg and put
together some fucking structure somewhere
that you're going to stuff with shit
and doing so in doing self feed.
This weird machine,
you're throwing money into it.
It's chewing the money up and
it's about to fucking give birth.
It's got its robot legs in the air and
it's robot pussies quiver and it's indeed
just just throwing money
into it's robot tits.
Yeah,
and it's just chewing that robe up,
money up and it's ready to give birth.
It's ready to give
birth as some sentience,
super intelligent thing that will
then give birth to other sentience and
superintelligent things figured out a way
to completely rewire the entire earth.
All of our waste will then
be converted into a positive.
Yeah.
Everything that's negative,
all pollution will be engineered out
of commission and into some sort of,
uh,
oxygen cleaning machine that it fuels
itself on pollution to the point where it
gets to a certain point
and when it runs out,
just spits flowers.
When it runs out,
it takes whatever remnants and
shoots flowers into the sky.
And as where you walk,
you're gonna have to rose petals falling
from the street because the sky's going
to be perfectly clear.
Sure.
North.
Yeah.
Why not?
It's,
it's,
I mean,
if you look at what's going on now
compared to what was going on a thousand
years ago,
this is a wonderful,
wonderful time.
And also in this book,
abundance,
uh,
highly recommend it for anybody using the,
not feeling like you're in hell.
Who wrote it?
I can't pronounce his name.
Can you look it up?
I'll look it up.
[inaudible] as he's one of the
cofounders of Singularity University,
uh,
let me look it up real quick.
And he's one of the guys that
thinks it's all going to be rosy.
Well,
I,
it's not like they think everything's,
they recognize that.
See this,
the thing about the Peter Diamandis,
yeah.
The,
the thing about this law of accelerating
returns is it doesn't just apply to
great things.
It also applies to chaos.
So,
so,
so these guys,
these new,
there was a hook.
These guys understand that the collapse,
the collapse is going to have the same
kind of velocity is the whatever this
thing is.
So that,
I don't think they're so naive about it,
they're just,
they've just recognize this what
we're calling up a baby being born.
They've recognized the things being born.
They can kind of predict
what phase of birth it's in.
And based on that prediction,
they can predict what's coming out next.
they can start working right now to
solve some of the big problems out there.
And one of the things
he says is that in a,
in a lot of countries,
you know,
the,
the amount of people that have phones
right now is just insane or the amount it
costs.
One example,
he gives us this,
the amount it would have
cost to light your house,
uh,
prior to electricity
with like wax candles or,
or,
or lanterns is so much more expensive and
the amount of cost to light your house
now,
it's so much cheaper.
The technology of lighting
is accessible to almost,
almost all levels of economy
except for the ultra super,
very,
very poor.
And there's a lot of them out there.
But having a light bulb in
your shack can still happen.
And if you have a light
bulb in your shack,
you're doing a hell of a lot better than
a lot of people used to have to have
tallow or I can't remember
what he called it,
like old school wax.
And there's a lot of other examples,
which is our,
like,
part of what he's saying is there's,
if there's a few problems
we have to solve right now,
uh,
one of them is clean water.
We've got to get clean water for the huge,
so many people in the world,
you just don't have it.
They're drinking poison every day.
So that's something
we've got to figure out.
Uh,
and then there's a few
other biggies like that.
And people I came are of the opinion that
these are very solvable problems based
on current predictions,
uh,
involving the direction that
technology technology is going in.
And Kurzweil's fucking
predictions are coming true,
man.
There's a lot of people
who roll their eyes at him.
Wazniak recently came out and said,
you know,
you used to think that staff was crap,
but now he's realizing it's true.
You know,
this is happening.
It's definitely happening.
And folks like Dia,
Mondelez or uh,
they're trying to steer the boat in the
direction of Utopia because they know
that it can be done.
And,
um,
wow.
Yeah,
it's cool.
People,
I've heard people criticize,
um,
Kurzweil's idea is saying that he
doesn't really understand human biology.
It doesn't understand
the biology of the brain.
But I think his point,
his point is I think is
that it's not gonna matter.
You're not going to have to be able to
replicate everything that the brain does
and how it does it in order to recreate
consciousness that consciousness may be
independent of that.
You might be able to literally,
you might be able to transfer it.
I hope so.
That's going to be so bizarre.
If that really does happen.
If they could figure out a way to download
your consciousness into a computer,
if that really becomes we,
right now it's like it's,
it's one of those things
that they're working on,
but it seems like a pipe dream,
right?
It doesn't it to you still
what to consciousness,
challenge building
consciousness into a computer.
That seems like a pipe.
Chase seems like a pipe dream until he,
okay,
so I'm not,
but I believe it could happen.
I'm sorry.
I think I blew it to happen.
I think it could too,
man.
You are an antenna.
You're they Iran antenna consisting of
all the nanoparticles all the way up to
what you are right now.
That combination of everything inside
the meat body that you're currently,
it's called Joe Rogan is in
some configuration right now.
It's in some exact configuration
or maybe in the deepest levels.
It's kind of like harmonic vibrations are
weird resonances that are happening in
the Nano tubules of your
dendrites or something.
But regardless the place,
what this thing in front of me right now,
the idea is if I duplicate exactly,
uh,
is it going to be you?
Is it going to be exactly
you as you are right now?
And if it's the,
if we really are antenna,
then yeah,
it's going to tune in the thing that
you're tuning in and maybe both of you,
we'll be tuning in at the same time.
Maybe they'll be this weird sense of
being stretched into two different forms.
It may be you will actually
have to extinguish one form
to experience the other
one.
Who the fuck knows?
That would be the ultimate poll,
right?
If they can prove that that form,
the form of virtual
life is more rewarding,
more powerful,
more beautiful.
I mean,
if you went into a virtual life,
if you plugged into the matrix and you
were in the Avatar and you were in love
with that blue chick and you're just
flying around on dragons together,
we might do it.
Dude,
you might do it.
I mean,
it might feel amazing.
It might feel just wonderful,
right?
I mean,
okay,
so if like,
let's imagine,
let's imagine that we could do this,
which is just because we've gotten to
the point in history where through some
form of analysis,
we can scan the human body
and tune consciousness in,
in virtual land.
Right?
But you're still out here.
It's just temporarily,
your consciousness has been transferred
into avatar world or you're flying
dragons,
uh,
making love to these
Amazonian blue skin women.
Imagine like an hour and a half of living
in this planet when you knew you had
to come back and you're like,
you know,
I don't think I'm going to come back.
I think I'm just going to stay.
How do you pay for it?
So you'll just have to get a
job while you're in the cloud.
Now Do,
you don't have to get a job.
You've been assimilated in the cloud.
You for your credit card comes
up in the cloud and they're like,
[inaudible],
we need needed to go on missions.
And you know what?
Yeah.
And I realize you have to earn your keep.
Even in the virtual world,
they don't tell you
that until you sign up.
Nobody would sign up if we told them that.
But you have to be our virtual slave to
pay for your virtual account so you can
keep riding virtual dragons here I want
to show you something really funny and
then it goes to either web cam or the
computer your body sitting in front of and
it's just some guys like mouth
fucking year paralyzed meat body.
That's a,
that's the thing too.
What happens to that?
To our bodies if we,
if our consciousness gets
transferred a very good point.
Are they going to do with all these
bodies and what if you want to go back,
can you go back and if you go back,
what have you,
what have you go back and you're like,
uh,
like a person with brain damage.
Like what if you go back
and you don't get it?
It's just,
it doesn't work anymore.
It's all fact,
right?
It's not quite right.
Or what happens when you're out of it
in some other fucking thing pops in and
pretends to be you.
Like what about that?
If we're tuning in stuff because really
what we're talking about here is if you
do believe we've gone real far match
though.
If we did transfer you
back and forth and you,
you went there and you were just a meat
box for a while and then you came back
like six months later but
you'll like brain damaged.
But you had fantastic stories.
Yeah,
he was just like,
they lend me back but
you can't believe what's
on the other side.
There's trackings they stayed,
they fly.
The dragons are the people who are big.
They're blue.
That's amazing.
They talked to the tree,
they link up at the tree,
that tree you seizure and they like try
to decide whether or not you're telling
the truth that we believe he's delusional.
Something happened to Dunkin.
We think he had some sort of a seizure
and when he returned he thought they did
live for seven years in the clouds.
It's giant blue people.
Obviously that didn't happen.
Okay.
It was only unconscious for
half an hour and you're like,
and you know,
you know what they don't know.
You know,
you know that you crossed over.
But you run out of money.
Well that's hilarious.
Kicked off backpage.
Well that is going to be part of it is
they take everything and then you'll,
you know like six years.
What happens after six years?
Right now.
Sign up for it.
I'm saying is you're going to your car
right now as you're walking to your car.
You're like,
guys,
if that was a good podcast,
man,
this is so cool.
I get to be Joe Rogan.
I was the UFC and a fucking awesome
and all of a sudden a pop up.
It's like a,
your credits have expired
for the Joe Rogan experience.
If you wish to continue.
Should I do I even fucking pay for this?
Then you just haven't come
to your some sweaty guys.
Sweaty,
Ethiopian and on wife
care on that fucking,
what's that cat?
That stuff they chew cot caught.
How'd he say it?
I don't know.
Jc Gusting someone gave me,
yeah,
you're just on a weird end.
Fetterman illuminating.
But you know,
man,
I think that I,
that's probably something that we're,
that's a,
that's a kind of thing we are going to
have to deal with based on this new VR.
I've seen.
Vr addiction is going to be a very,
very real thing.
So you called me,
uh,
when I was in front of the Improv,
I picked up the phone,
I've told about 10 people in
the store and you're like,
dude,
just changes everything.
Yeah.
This is bigger than the Internet.
And I was like,
what?
And I was really high and it was about
to go on stage and I was listening to
this whole like,
what the fuck dude?
Like what,
what are you talking about?
Like what happened?
And you told me about
this video that you saw,
like explaining the video
of going up to the up piano.
Oh yeah.
The video.
This is like,
you know,
Shit's gotten like five,
probably 10 times better
since that's by the way,
but this was a,
it's a demo of um,
uh,
Oculus oculus rift and you put this on
and suddenly you're like in a loft in New
York and uh,
you're watching this guy,
he's like looking at you like he knows
you and he's smoking a cigarette and he
starts playing piano and you look around,
you're in a fucking waft man.
It looks like it's like tracked perfectly.
It was,
it was,
it looks,
you're suddenly in this other
place and it feels really intimate.
Like it feels like,
you know the guy,
this is before I tried VR porn.
Who by the way,
um,
which I must have told
you that we stumble.
I must have told you about it.
You have to pee.
I don't have to pay because I know,
sorry,
I'm wriggling around.
No,
but you,
I know you,
you told me,
you warned me.
I warned Joe van through two hours.
Like,
like a champion.
I can't,
well that's cause I squeezed it out
right before I like before he came on,
squeezed it.
But yeah,
if you tried Vr porn and I'm scared,
I'm scared to lose my life
in that it's from the porn.
Lose your life in Vr porn.
Jesus Christ.
Joe,
you're going to try it.
Doodoo Doodoo do to to
to to eat a hash cookie.
Put on the Vr porn goggles.
Slap warm baby oil all over your cock.
Yeah.
No,
you're not going to slab
warm baby oil sex with you.
Yeah.
You're going to put some kind of sleeve
on your car that is going to perfectly
replicate exactly what's
happening inside the VR.
Do you think you'd be at one pump
Trump under those circumstances?
The first time
he does it,
you fucking,
a day I'd go to Doug and says,
hey man,
I haven't seen you for a while,
so I thought I'd just check in on you.
You've lost 50 pounds and she,
she sunk it in your eyeball deep
in the back of your head like,
hey man,
you got any water,
any liquids,
man,
you got any PDLA caucus just been rubbed
down to some kind of really like red.
You can see tendril,
outer layers of the onion
have been peeled away
first time,
which feel one pump,
chunk
his picture.
You'll fucking pizza boxes
stacking up mountain dew.
You just fucking hands up in the air.
My Chihuahua chewing
discarded come Napkins.
Just cause I as an evening days.
So it's just trying to
get protein from anything.
You Bet.
You faintly hear the bark over the crazy
loud three d porn coming out of the
fucking Sennheiser headphones.
You're talking like,
just ignore it.
Put it,
goddammit.
I can't come up with
this fucking dog barking.
Yeah,
you're going to put it back back.
That's it.
But that is,
that is it.
That's what you're looking at,
man.
You're that crazy.
Yeah.
Well I mean,
yeah man.
I mean this is,
I'm terrified because porn is already,
uh,
for,
I'm sure that from time to time you
occasionally will look upon porn,
having them.
Imagine you do from time to time.
And it's already incredibly
engrossing just in today's space.
So when suddenly you find yourself,
uh,
in a,
in a room,
I,
that's not your room with a girl
that you've never seen in your life,
writing you and looking at you like she
really loves you and then you look down
and it's not your body anymore
and that's not your cock.
And he looked back up at
this beautiful girl.
He seems to really like,
she's known you for a long time.
It seems like you're in a really
good part of your relationship.
You know what I mean?
Like,
uh,
that's the one that I saw,
but it's like,
uh,
for a lot of people,
I think that's going to be
real hard to come back from.
It's going to be real hard to
peel those goggles off and uh,
walk into your living room where
your wife is passed out on the,
on the Sofa,
and maybe your blanket falls down and all
the farts that have been held in there
from the Campbell's chunky
soup did she ate earlier,
come wafting up into your face.
Oh,
you know,
and you look down at your body and it's,
it's just a normal body.
It's not the ripped tattooed dude
who is fucking whoever that girl was.
And you're going to like have this strange
kind of a virtual jet lag where you
have to accept that the paradigm that
you're existing in is not a perfect
paradigm that's going to be
hard for a lot of people to,
uh,
to deal with.
I think that's going to be a real,
a real problem.
That's a real problem,
man.
I think it's,
I think you're right.
And I think,
I think
the visual aspect of it and just having
the robot thing on your Dick thought so
crude,
that's like one step.
They're going to figure out a way to tap
those ideas directly into your brand.
You're going to be able to experience it.
You're gonna be able to experience it.
I think it's probably
going to come in the form.
Obviously I have no idea what
the fuck I'm talking about.
But if I had to guess,
like if I had just random
speculation on the future,
I think we're gonna find a way to
record memories on a device in HD there.
They're going to find a way to either do
something with the eyes or figure out a
way through something you wear to
tune in to the reality that you're
experiencing from head to toe tuna,
right?
Tuna didn't sit through a frequency,
record it on some sort of a hard drive,
a little tiny flash thing,
and we'll have a little flash
thing in the back of our head.
Or who knows,
man,
maybe we'll even all just be in the
cloud all around you all the time.
That's more likely,
very likely,
and you will be able to dip into the
Bank of other people's experiences.
You will have the antenna that'll shoot
right into our memory or write into our
mind or right into our
experience center and boom,
I'm live in Duncan trussell's life.
I'm snowboarding as Duncan
Trussell and when it right,
and I start with it,
Jimmy Hendrix,
manic depression is playing.
No,
no.
Don't you wake up snowboarding in your
body listening to Jimi Hendrix and I'm
living your life for the next hour or
two hours that you recorded this and put
it up on Youtube.
That's what you two becomes.
Two becomes.
Everybody gets to live cranes.
You are living,
it goes total.
Next level.
It makes youtube today
look like cave drawings.
Yeah,
figure out a way to tap deep,
deep into the actual memory itself.
Even missing dog.
Even like thinking when I get home,
I'm going to definitely
throw out that toilet.
You know all that stuff.
It's going to be in your head.
You're going to be all of it recorded,
all of it.
We're going to be in an ocean of memories
digitally recorded in the cloud and
also don't forget,
possibly,
maybe suddenly graveyards are preserved.
Brains become reservoirs of old memories,
so you might even be able to
harvest the memories of the dead.
You know you might.
Who knows if epigenetics,
if,
if these memories are
being stored are encoded.
Maybe you could go into the DNA of
a mummy and have Einstein's brain.
I hope they'll die.
I don't know.
I feel like these
preserved Einstein's brain.
I think they got us
doing experiments on it.
Shit.
Trying to find out why it was so wacky,
strong,
super powerful.
Can you imagine that?
Imagine the fucking waking Einstein up
and of computer and the first thing he's
like,
what?
Wait,
where am I?
What?
What have you done?
Yeah,
you fucking assholes done.
Who would let you do this?
Yeah.
Okay,
shut me off.
He's having a great time
and he's up in heaven.
No,
I'm not going to shut you off.
I'm going to drop you
into world of Warcraft.
I know.
What are you going to do,
Einstein?
You better get some magic clean.
You gotta level up.
That's going to be weird
to think that we are.
We're going to be able to re to resurrect
anyone whose DNA still exists and drop
them into video games and
tortures and just for fun.
Well that when you were talking
about porn being a real problem,
the other thing that's going to be
a real problem is that video games,
video games are going
to be a crazy problem.
This is awesome.
As they are now.
Dude,
I get jealous.
I was watching this thing on kim.com
kim.com was apparently like the number one
call of duty player in
the world at one point.
You know who he is,
right?
He's the Guy who runs a mega upload.
Yep.
And they took all of his money.
It's like this crazy thing with America.
They're saying he's fleeing justice
because he won't come to America,
stays in New Zealand and reports are,
he's the coolest guy ever.
He seems very,
very,
very cool.
And um,
for whatever reason.
Anyway,
the point is they should,
they had this tour of his house and uh,
you know,
it was kind of going over
the details of his case,
but I was watching like his video game
room's got to like a room where he plays
this fucking game.
I can't even watch it for a few minutes
and watch her for a few minutes ago.
God,
that must be fucking awesome.
That must be so awesome to play.
Come.
Maybe I'll just get into it from,
no,
I can't fucking do it.
But this is going to be nothing.
This is almost like a pitstop.
You don't even have to take like,
dude,
hold you.
Are you this hungry?
Cause in the half an hour
there's a Kentucky Fried
Chicken and they got that new
double double.
If you had that,
you know,
it's like you pass like Mike Shit Burgers,
you know and you know like it just
hang on for another half hour.
That's what it feel like.
It's like what they're coming
out with with these goggles.
Yeah.
That evening.
Sorry.
Carmax had it to me the other day.
He asked me if I had been in doctor dated.
Oh,
I saw that tweet man.
I turned green with jealousy.
Carmax tweeting you.
That's incredible,
man.
I met him a bunch of times,
Holy Shit.
Quake against his crew.
That was nuts.
Yeah,
I saw that.
Yeah.
One of the coolest things ever,
dude.
He's right about indoctrinated too
because it is an indoctrination it in the
people who like indoctrinate you like
my pal Johnny Ross when he brought me to
this special room to try this VR shit out.
He's like,
get ready,
get ready.
This will change you.
This is going to blow your mind.
He's totally right to mash it.
Fly to Dallas,
you and me.
We should film it for the show.
The show that we're going to do,
which is fly to Dallas
and hang out with carmax.
That'd be awesome.
He's,
he's an intimidatingly intelligent.
We definitely need to get you
to try out the most outdated.
You need to try it.
You gotta try it.
Skirt.
Of course.
I'll try it,
but I'm scared thing.
Is this a,
the new magic leap thing?
That video they put out last week of this
is supposedly what it's going to look
like.
Okay.
Let's see what magic leap looks like here.
Can the folks at home
see some version of this?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to go pee all the
time and make that happen.
Tonkin decays healthy,
new,
healthy fit,
Dunkin,
keeping it together.
Dunkin.
Oh my God.
So this magic leap,
it lets holograms appealing
appear in front of you and the,
they're spinning.
This person in this video
is spinning these holograms,
moving them around and stretching them
and touching them as if they're the
interface.
On a computer just loaded up the game.
You got to play a video game right now.
So he's about to play a video
game right now in his head.
This is fucking insane.
And he grabs a gun?
Yeah.
Where's he get that gun?
That's plastic gun,
right?
Or it's a visual virtual.
We can't be virtual because
he's holding in his hand.
I think it's virtual.
No chance.
What they're trying to say.
That's what they're trying to say.
Yeah.
I think I'd be,
I'd rather have a real gun.
Cause a real gun.
But this is pretty dope.
So he's playing video games at his house?
Yeah.
He's shooting things that
are in his house with,
this might be the end of the world.
Okay.
Come on dude.
Who's going to fucking go
outside and play stick ball.
Tell me that.
What kid is going to go play
stickball when you can do this.
This is the dopest shit
the world has ever seen.
Oh my God,
man.
Oh my God.
You get an attack by a robot.
This is terrifying.
Oh yeah.
The key here,
the guys scream,
oh shit.
He's like literally out of breath,
kids are going to get in shape.
We're going to develop super warriors
because they're going to be constantly
running around.
Yeah.
Around
playing video games.
I'm one of those Omni
Directional treadmills.
Yeah.
That's just insane,
man.
You haven't seen a black mirror yet,
but a lot of the stuff you
guys are just talking about.
They talked about it at all.
Yeah,
I'm the new episode.
Don't spoiler alert it because everybody
told me that the new episode is
insanely good.
You got to see it.
What's everything you had Duncan
just talk about of course episode.
That's of course.
Have you seen the new episode of uh,
what is it called again?
Black Mirror and I've seen it.
I've seen one episode of
that show and I liked it.
It was,
it was weird as pig fucking episode.
The Zealand laughs a,
yeah,
that was good.
It's Whoa.
It's like what kind of a
crazy fucking show is this?
I mean that was a really interesting
dilemma that guy was facing.
Yeah,
that was a fascinating show.
But the new one is supposed to be awesome
and deals with a lot of the stuff that
we just talked about.
There's a bunch of people that are
aware that we're in some weird space.
We just showed the games that you play
on magic leap and I see that we just
shoot the people in your living room.
You get robots coming after you.
It's insane.
Insanely cool.
Yeah,
that,
that's right man.
That,
that stuff is really cool.
That's,
that's the data visualization,
you know,
that's the idea that we're sort of
surrounded by this midst of data and that
technology is going to visualize
it and all these new ways.
Like currently the way it's visualized
is in two d on the screen in our pockets.
But the idea of like,
you know,
just cool shit like as you're driving
your tweets or any tweets at you come
flying into your car or you know,
tweets will become three d things
floating around people or my friend,
my friend Pemberton says uh,
it's all gonna be Johnny
Palmer and funny guy but he's,
he,
he says that it's going to be like credit
is going to become the new form of a
leadism and that you're in
your augmented reality land,
your credit score can float around you.
So people get,
you know,
that kind of shit.
Like it's going to be weird cause the way
that the people build themselves up is
in augmented reality is
going to be hilarious.
Like the trophies,
you were like little augmented
reality metals that you'll wear.
Cause you know like you know,
it's a big deal for people.
My Twitter followers,
you know what I mean?
People were really into that.
The number of Twitter followers you have
is that some kind of indication of your
fame.
So that kind of shit,
people are going to figure out ways to,
to wear it and augmented reality space.
And kind of subtle ways,
but ways that people can see it.
It used to be if you wanted
to brag about your success,
the way you would visualize
it was by wearing gold.
You know what I mean?
It's that people still do it right?
They want to show their,
they want it subtly.
Say I'm a rich mother fucker by showing
you their Kohl's watcher gold chains.
It's like,
see,
I'm actually wearing a rare metal
that's cause I'm doing good.
Recognize it,
but the new way of doing that,
it's going to be,
you know,
Shit.
There really is more relevant,
which is like,
you know what?
What are you going to look
like in that virtual world?
I mean,
if it's predicated on
how much money you have,
like what if you,
what if you look like that Persian
guy from 300 the giant guy.
What was his name?
Xerxes.
Yeah.
How about that shits on.
That's when you're super
bowl and you're 10 feet tall,
10 foot tall Persian dude,
but cool earrings.
But you can only look like that if
you've got a 700 credit score and have a
Citibank card,
but you can look like that if you have
a 700 credit score and a Citibank card,
you can look like that.
Yeah.
That's something to aspire to.
Dunkin feed the machine because it's like,
think of that.
What's that stupid car
thing that everybody,
that people get really into the black
American Express who's got the black,
but it's like things that like stupid
stupid ways that we try to like this
stupid tail feathers that you tried
it and he's a baller dunk control.
He's got a black or or the or the like,
you know,
there's just so many ways that people
try to d or The new ad and an apple watch
and if you want,
you can get one for $19,000 with a gold
chain and then like he can go around and
show everybody luck.
I'm allowed Ed.
If it's 10 grand,
10 grand for the Super Spencer one
Tangere isn't something like that.
It's crazy.
But still,
it's very funny though.
The way we try to indicate our worth
or value is through a rare metal,
uh,
when,
when what it really indicates a person's
value these days is not so much like
can you afford to wear a rare metal?
It's a lot of other
stuff that goes into it.
You know,
it's not just the jewels
that you were or you know,
like that's a thing you give
your girlfriend a diamond
and then they wear it.
Are there,
some women are,
so you know,
like the thing,
it's like a,
it's a boring class shea
in movies where it's like,
Ooh,
he got you a giant diamond
and it's like a big,
it's a,
it's a big deal.
That's just so funny the way that we,
those things are going to be
outdated with augmented reality.
It's going to be certain add ons to your
physical form that you can only obtain
via shit.
Tons of money or some others.
Social,
online standing,
which demonstrates your
worth in the cloud.
So for now,
embrace the physical reality,
enjoy the shit out of the
cheeseburgers and milkshakes.
Yes.
Sex.
And you know,
just have a good time.
Give a lot of hugs out cause
it's gonna get real virtual.
Yeah,
that's right.
Real quick.
Yeah.
It's coming.
Get all the reality
stuff out while you can.
That's right.
Within a hundred years,
it's not going to be here.
We're all going to be living
inside a cloud 10 10 years,
10 years.
Geez.
I'd say 10 I mean 10 years in,
we're all in some odd,
we're all aware it using some form
of augmented reality technology,
but all these people,
man,
when you ask them,
the people who are really
like in the know about this,
when you ask them what do
you predict in 10 years,
they're like,
forget it man.
You,
you want me to tell you what things are
gonna look like when they're five times
as fast as they are now?
That's what you want me to tell you.
You want me to predict what
kind of innovations come
from an apple computer five
times as fast as the fastest
apple computer on planet earth?
I can't do that.
It's impossible to guess.
We don't know.
It's a big fucking question mark.
Especially when you start
talking about decades.
Yeah.
Can't do it.
Who decades.
Yeah,
go back.
Go back in time.
10 years and predict this.
How,
how,
how accurately would you have predicted
some of the things happening right now
and I wouldn't have predicted Uber.
You wouldn't have predicted most things.
Who would?
Who would have predicted podcasts?
Let's go there.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
Do you remember that Christian Slater
movie where he was the rebel that was
broadcasting
the pirate radio show?
Do you remember that?
He had a run and hide.
He was broadcasting
out that it's so funny.
I'm going to have to
watch that to tie it up,
man.
He's fucking going to play the cool songs.
Not that fucking Jessie's girl bullshit.
You listening to
me?
Well,
Jessie's girl is a bad ass jam.
You know?
Maybe Christian Slater
just has obscure tastes.
He doesn't have to shove it down,
throw it.
What he needs to do it was by a god
damn radio license like everybody else.
Well,
I'll set up a business or
government.
Why doesn't he do that?
Why does he have to be a pirate?
He needs to get licensed,
get licensed,
pay the government there due to criminal
broadcasting music through the sky
without a license.
It's ridiculous.
He had a,
he had a fucking dangerous situation.
He was running from the cops,
but it was more important to
him to continue broadcasting
shitty music over the
forbidden skies to fight the
found that it was to stay free.
He was going to take chances.
He was so beautiful,
had great bone structure,
such a cute man with a sort of
young Jack Nicholson thing going.
Daria is broadcasting from his car,
pump up the volume to food there.
He gets on the first podcast
or pump up the volume.
He was the first podcaster.
He was driving around yelling at people.
The Sky's falling and they were like,
God dammit,
we're so glad you're here.
It's so funny,
the idea that some young guy too,
it was,
it's always great.
Like some young guy who gets it and
there's like these older people that just
don't get it.
Email how annoying this
dude be in real life.
Some young guy driving on the street,
they'd government is stealing.
Taxes are stealing.
Oh.
Oh,
this fucking guy.
I don't know what he was protesting about.
What was the protesting about
wanting to play the smiths.
I need,
do I need to educate your people
and could fucking music Kubo.
Let's play vine.
Oh Dude,
I remember that movie.
I thought I thought he was
the coolest fucking guy.
Talk.
He's the coolest guy ever.
Yeah,
girls would love him.
I walk.
Can I be him?
I wish I was a rebel.
God.
I says movies.
Those guys would be so perfect.
I God,
I wish I could be like John
Cusack can say anything.
Just stand there with a boom box
on my head and get the girl back.
Or what's his name and what
about footloose remember
footloose I wish I was so
free that I could come to some small
town and dance and still try to pick up
girls.
Some top 10 that I'm not gay.
I'm just showing up dancing.
Who the fuck is dancing?
Kevin Bacon.
That's who bitch shows up.
He's got fucking moves.
He's been practicing.
Whoa,
whoa.
How come you haven't been
doing man type shit sign?
How come you,
he shows up hanging
around Barnes and shit,
bleeding,
dancing and they,
they overthrow the old fuddy duddies.
That's right.
The fucking preacher
had the sluttiest girl,
the daughter member,
yet preacher's daughter.
He was banging her.
She was a little upset.
Classic.
I guess that's what the singularity is,
right?
It's just Kevin Bacon coming to our
dimension and like teaching us all how to,
how to overcome the oppression of old
power structures were just in footloose
fancy to step [inaudible].
Who's fixes everything?
Kenny Loggins songs.
God,
I heard that song the other day.
Footloose well,
how about there's fucking
geniuses that remade that movie.
How about that?
How long someone sat around,
they remade it.
Oh,
they already did.
They already did it.
Yeah.
Someone watched footloose and goes,
God damn,
we need to do this again.
How come,
how come they haven't
done that with road house?
Okay.
You know,
and they need to do that dude from,
uh,
the HBO show,
Danny Mcbride,
you know Danny the hilarious dude.
Oh yeah,
man,
totally.
He needs to do roadhouse.
That'd be amazing to his version
of how he needs to do anything.
That's one of the hang on its own.
However,
if he did a real,
if they did the exact same script
exactly the way it happened,
I bet it would be one
of the funniest movies.
So it will be sell funny.
It'd be incredible.
You should pitch that to
Danny Mcbride and for that's the
Sam guy with the thick mustache.
Danny trio.
Uh,
yeah,
I'm a casting agent.
Yeah,
that would be an amazing move.
Who wouldn't?
That's a great God damn fucking movie.
Danny Mcbride as Patrick Swayze and
Danny Tree Hill as that Sam doodle fine.
Sam,
what is his name?
God dammit,
the guy who does the truck commercials.
Ram trucks.
Ram tough.
It doesn't he do around?
I'm not sure you mean I'm confused.
I thought you were talking about
the guy who used to be in jail.
The Ram.
Yeah,
but I'm talking about the guy in the
roadhouse movie in the roadhouse movie.
What is his name?
Sam Elliott.
That's right.
You know who?
Sam Elliott,
his son.
How dare you?
You know Sam Elliot is right.
No,
I just want to lie and say I do.
I'm in Paris.
I'm looking it up right now.
I'll pull it up for you.
There he is.
Oh yes.
That guy.
Yeah,
sure.
I know.
You know that guy is so in
the Danny Mcbride version.
Dot.
Guys prayed by Danny Trejo.
Oh that's cool.
Cause he,
he's the guy that gets jacked and then
I don't want to spoil alert Roadhouse,
but he's the guy that get jacked and
then the Patrick Swayze guy has to go in
and kick some ass.
So who plays the Badass
dude who plays this guy?
There was,
there were some other guys
they would back up real quick.
I want to show the guys
that they would fight with.
There's some other dudes,
right?
I don't know.
It's just all pictures of him.
That's not necessarily all roadhouse.
What there was whoever,
there was a guy who was the number
one karate guy that Patrick Swayze.
He had to fight [inaudible] excuse me.
And the guy at the end where he kills him.
Remember that?
Yeah.
That was the guy that he brought
in the fucking super bad ass guy.
I dunno who plays him.
That guy.
Yes.
I vote for Mario Lopez.
Perfect.
Yup.
Handsome.
Beautiful.
Have you seen the F can act,
can box if he seen the fist foot way?
Of course I have so fucking guy's,
that guy's genius.
He's genius.
He's just funny as shit all times.
He is so funny.
Did you see that movie,
the end or this is the end?
Whatever the one who was with
James Franco and no broken.
I'm glad that your mind
has to see that shit.
Is He funny in that movie?
Holy Shit.
Is he funny in that movie that was like,
that might be as funny as role
ever and I'm not bullshitting.
I hate when people say that and I said
we can't wait to watch it and I'm not
bullshitting.
Maybe sometimes the bullshit,
but I got to go soon.
I do too.
So what a crappy,
crappy way to end the podcast.
I'm sorry.
There's no good way to end these things.
Excuse me,
ladies and gentlemen,
there's no good way to
end these things there.
They're two fun,
right?
We were too high starting out.
I wasn't [inaudible].
I was a little on the high side.
God Damn,
I was tumbling because I had a point,
but we were,
we were both so energetic
and so energized to say it,
but I had a point about like super left
wing people and it totally lost it in
mid thought.
Oh I didn't know where it went,
but that's a pretty good job.
Talking about how they disguise their
aggression and their in the clothes or
whatever the thing is they're doing.
It's just here people are going to use it.
Some.
Some people are going to use symbols,
structures to try to make the world a
better place and some people are going to
use symbols,
structures to punchy with.
It's like somebody who's like
putting on like a a a boxing glove.
It's like it's like a velvet glove.
It's like someone
punching you with velvet.
It's,
there's still punching me.
That's why it feels like shit when you
get around people who are inflicting
their aggression on you at some kind of,
I think it's ultimately
a good lesson though.
It's told to me less than that.
There's,
there's no real one ideology that's
got it nailed and you're going to have
weirdos in every single group.
And the,
the real thing that we have to all sort
of come to some sort of an agreement on
is that we're all part of this organism,
right?
That's,
that's what we keep getting to.
The only way to fix this thing is if we
all really do have some sort of ultimate
power.
Like if technology continues to
exponentially increase the point where the
average person can just hit
the universe reset switch is,
there's too much power.
There's just,
it becomes some crazy singularity moment
where the average person has waiting,
you mean the power that you have and
your phone is so indescribable to someone
who lived in ancient Rome.
It's,
it's indescribable.
And if it continues that
way and somehow or another,
the cat gets out of the bag and
they invent some way to literally,
everybody has the power to stop life
as we know it at any given time.
Yeah.
It was the oldest.
The only way everybody looks at everybody
as just as important is that it's
really almost the only
way to cure the disease.
That is the craziness of humanity,
the craziness of humanities,
like this weird thing where we can,
we can be to human beings,
can either be madly love or the best
of friends are so appreciative of each
other or at each other's throats trying
to kill each other with their fingers.
There's no real present shit like trying
to hit each other in the head with
rocks fighting.
It could easily happen one way or
the other and the amount of times,
and it happens the
right way is incredible.
If you look at the numbers
that we're dealing with,
300 plus million people in this country,
the amount of kindness and the amount
of happiness is off the charts,
right?
Just not salacious.
It doesn't draw us in.
It doesn't scare us,
so we don't focus on it.
And by not focusing on it in his stead,
focusing on fear or focusing
on hay or focusing on blame,
we sorta perpetrate it and the more people
could focus on figuring out a way to
just interface as nicely with all
the people around you as possible,
as friendly and easily with all
the people around you as possible.
The more you can figure
out a way to do that,
the better off the whole
planet is in a whipple,
it'll rip and there's going
to be people that violate it.
It's going to be people
that don't play along.
It's going to be built to try to exploit
it and fucked up just a man or man.
Eventually we'll figure that out.
Eventually we'll overwhelm that.
There's a new ethic and a new ethic
is brought about by this way that we
communicate now.
That's right.
That doesn't exist before
and,
and I think also you have to become,
you have to become a person of action
like your friend or you're talking about.
He's like,
he's helping people
get water in the Congo.
Dude,
anyone listening can become that guy.
Anyone listening right now can start
taking steps in the direction of doing
that.
And if you don't have time,
go to fight for the forgotten.
Just Google fight for the forgotten.
I think it's fight for the forgotten.org.
I'll,
I'll pull it up right now cause he's cool
as far as what I didn't say anything.
So Jamie did didn't,
um,
I think it's fight for the forgotten.com.
Yes it is.
It's fight for the forgotten.com.
One word fight for the forgotten.com.
Just a genuine,
real cool guy.
A real sweet guy.
And you know,
I mean he kind of throws into the face
the idea that a lot of people have about
him and may fighters too.
They think they're brutes and,
and you know mean people.
He couldn't be kinder.
I mean,
look at this picture of him
hanging out with these pygmies.
Oh Wow.
You do this as real as they can to us.
I just love that guy.
I love that guys like that exist.
It's just a,
it was a,
we,
we live in a cool time,
man.
We live in a cool time.
Um,
Duncan motherfuckin trial.
Can I make an announcement cast?
Yes.
Ah,
I'm going to be at the EGM.
Prive doing a live podcast
recording on April 18th the Improv.
Where here?
Oh my.
Well,
I've podcasting course California,
the Los Angeles and prior,
Oh my God.
Look intranasal live podcasts
with Danieli Bolelli Jesus.
God working on a third guest.
I don't know how to
see that's happening.
Yeah,
that is the Saturday night.
I guess it is in my,
it might be off on the day.
I think it's the 18th or the 19th but
you can look on my website is a Saturday,
April 18th here.
Let me look at 2015 right now.
It's on my website.
I'm doing a lot of live podcasts coming
up on the lungs because it is so fun,
man.
It is so fun to do.
It really is a black it almost
as much as you like stand up.
Yes.
Yes I do.
I do it well just
because it's like you're,
it's a lot longer than his standup show.
These things always end up being a
lot longer and there's just more,
I dunno man,
you,
it's,
I like connecting with
people out there and I,
it's a new medium.
It's like a new medium and it's fun to
play around with it and see like the best
way to do it and what works
and what doesn't work.
It is a,
Hollywood is on the hold on the 18th.
Yeah,
that's the 18th with Daniela [inaudible].
Uh,
and I don't know who the f I'm
working on the next or the other,
either guest right now.
I'm still putting the show together,
but uh,
yeah,
a lot of cool.
I podcast coming up.
I can Arlington in Cambridge,
Philadelphia and the ones in Brooklyn
or sold out Duncan trussell.com sold out
in Brooklyn.
Son.
I love you.
We love you Dunkin.
All Right Ladies and gentlemen,
that's it for this day
of fun and podcasting.
Thanks to a doctor,
Andrew Hill,
who was my first guess and
thanks to a Duncan Trussell.
I'm right back with as you don't
necessarily have to listen to.
Bye.
Hello?
Okay.
Hmm.
Good one man.